GOOD THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER
WELCOME EVERYBODY THE HEARING
ROOM IS OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE FOR
THIS HEARING ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WHO IS ATTENDING US IN
PERSON IN THIS BUILDING IS
ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES WHILE YOU'RE IN THE
BUILDING. WE ALSO ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE NOTED ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAYBE READ
INTO THE RECORD A REPRINTED.
EVERYONE IS ENCOURAGED TO WATCH
THE HEARING FROM ITS LIVE STREAM
ON THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. YOU
CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR BY USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW TWO MINUTES EACH FOR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
IN OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL.
ADDITIONAL WITNESS COMMENTS WILL
BE LIMITED ONLY TO YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE
ONE AND YOUR POSITION AND THAT'S
THAT'S ALL. ADDITIONAL LEVY ARM
WE WILL START WITH THOSE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN
THE ROOM FOR THAT TESTIMONY AND
THEN MOVED TO THE PHONE LINES.
TO USE OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE THE
NUMBER TO CALL IS. 877-692-8950
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ELEVEN HUNDRED
AND DON'T WORRY IF YOU DIDN'T
WRITE THAT DOWN BECAUSE YOU CAN
FIND THOSE NUMBERS AGAIN ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH ARE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2890 THREE AND OUR STAFF
WILL TRY TO HELP NOW IF YOU'RE
ON WITH THE OPERATOR AND FOR
SOME REASON YOUR CALL GETS
DROPPED DO YOU HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL. ONES JUST CALL RIGHT
BACK IN AND WE'LL TRY TO GET YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. OUT FINALLY
IN THE ASSEMBLY HAS
UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCE A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE FLOOR
PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS STRICTLY PROHIBITED.
SUCH CNDUCT MAY INCLUDE TALKING
OR MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF
MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE BILL OR SPEAKING
ON OTHER BILLS THAT WERE NOT
PICKING UP AT THAT MOMENT AND
OTHER DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
AND MAKING MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
DO THE PEOPLE'S WORK. I WILL
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP. I WILL MORE THAN THAT
CONTINUE DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT
IN THEIR REMOVAL FROM THE
BUILDING. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD OF THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT. I MAY
TEMPORARILY HAVE TO RECESS THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
EXPORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM-THE BUILDING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. AND WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN OUR HEARING. ADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FRIEDMAN HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE FONG. ON HERE
BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HERE DALY YOUR DAILY HERE DAVIES
. GIPSON KALRA OVER HERE LEE LEE
HERE MEDINA DEAN HERE IN THIS
AREA. THE VERY PRESENT WHEN.
WELL DONALD WARD WICKS. WE HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE THREE MEASURES ON CONSENT
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY TWO AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY TWO IS OUR MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT PILE. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND OF MISS
AMOUNT OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ADAMS ON CONSENT
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG FONG
AYE BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I DAILY DAILY I
DAVIES. GIPSON KALRA. ALL RIGHT
I LI LI I MEDINA. MEDINA I AM
VERY. ZERO EIGHT THAT WOULD BE A
THANK YOU AT THE VERY. WE HAVE
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO OKAY THAT THEY
CAN CENTRAL THERE'S A DOCTOR
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WERE MOVING NOW
TO OUR FIRST BILL A. B. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BRIAN. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY SIR AND WELCOME.
I WOULD HAVE TO SERGEANTS TO SO
MAKE SURE THAT HIS BILL IS LIVE
THE TROUBLE. UP OR THE
MICROPHONES PLUGGED IN. LIKE A
TRICK MICROPHONE.
ON MONDAY I AM WILL SIT DOWN.
WITH GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR-
AND COLLEAGUES FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR ALL OF HER
WORK ON THIS BILL I ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T SPENT MORE TIME WITH
ANOTHER CHAIR TALKING THROUGH
POLICY AND ALSO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS. AND THIS TEAM FOR
WORKING WITH US TODAY IRAQ'S
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
JUST SPONSORED BY THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA
. BUT THIS BIL WOULD DO IS
REMOVE A FINANCIAL BARRIER TO
PEOPLE SEEKING TO BECOME HOUSED.
IN SPECIFICALLY FOR PEOPLE
LIVING IN THEIR VEHICLES BY
CREASING OPTIONS FOR TICKET
FORGIVENESS. LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THERE WERE SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
. FOR ANNOUNCED THERE ARE NEARLY
NINETEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THEIR VEHICLES FOR MANY
THEIR VEHICLE IS THE LAST
VESTIGE OF STABILITY THE ONLY
THING KEEPING THEM FROM BEING
DIRECTLY ON THE SIDEWALKS. THEIR
ONLY PROTECTION FROM THE
ELEMENTS AND IT'S THE ONLY SAFE
PLACE THAT THEY CAN STORE THEIR
BELONGINGS. VEHICLES ALSO A
LIFELINE TO EXIT HOMELESSNESS.
THE MOBILITY OF THE VEHICLE CAN
HELP YOU GET A JOB ACCESS HEALTH
CARE ME WITH THE CASE MANAGER.
OR PLY FOR NEEDED BENEFITS. YEAH
MANY OF OUR NEIGHBORS LIVING IN
THEIR VEHICLES AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR VEHICLES. SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF THE PARKING TICKETS. BUT THEY
CASES PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE SCRAPING MONEY
TOGETHER TO PAY THESE TICKETS
OFF. OR TURNING TO HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND BEGGING
THEM FOR FINANCIAL SUPPORT. THIS
BILL LOOKS TO BUILD ON THE
SUCCESS OF PROGRAMS IN VARIOUS
CITIES HAVE CREATED TICKET
FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS TO SOLVE
THIS VERY ISSUE. AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD ASK THAT ALL
OF OUR CITIES CREATE A TICKET
TICKET FORGIVENESS PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE GIVING PEOPLE LIVING IN
THEIR VEHICLES A PATHWAY TO
STABILITY. INSTEAD OF PUSHING
PEOPLE DEEPER INTO CRISIS OR
MAKING IT HARDER FOR THEM. TO
BECOME HOUSE. HELLO THIS IS HARM
REDUCTION. IT'S ALSO GOOD
GOVERNANCE WE SPEND MORE MONEY
TRYING TO COLLECT THE PENALTIES
AND FEES WE IMPOSE WITH VEHICLE
CITATIONS FOR PEOPLE ON WHO ARE
ON HOUSING WE ACTUALLY END UP
COLLECTING. WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO CRIMINALIZE AND PENALIZE
OUR WAY OUT OF HOMELESSNESS.
ADDITION THIS BILL DOES HAVE A
LIMIT THOUGH. AND THAT'S FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS. IT ALSO WORKS
WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS TO VERIFY
THAT SOMEBODY AND IS. ELIGIBLE
TO GET WAIVERS MAY BE VERIFIED
THROUGH CONTINUE OF CARE OF
SERVICE PROVIDERS INCLUDING
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS LEGAL
SEARCH RIDERS AND OTHERS. THIS
IS A SMART BILL AT THE TIME THE
BILL IT WON'T SOLVE OUR CRISIS
BUT IT'LL TAKE A STEP FURTHER.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AFTER YOUR PATENT AN
ADVOCATE FOR CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. AND SHAUN
PLEASANCE. SOMEBODY WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES ON THE BOARD OF THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY. THANK YOU TO MINISTRY
TO WITNESS PLEASE I THINK THERE
BY PHONE AS WELL MANAGER OKAY
OPERATOR IF WE CAN PLEASE BRING
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF. AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOUR LINES ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES- PLEASE
GIVE ME ONE SECOND HERE ARE
GATHER MY INFORMATION HERE
APOLOGIZE AGAIN. TO THE BOARD-
OKAY MY NAME IS STEVE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE MY NAME IS THEODORE
PATTEN I AM IS THE S. H. SPEAK
UP ADVOCATE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS AND I
AM HONORED TO BE SPEAKING TO YOU
ALL TODAY BACK IN OCTOBER TWENTY
FIFTEEN YOU KNOW TO PERSONAL
ISSUES AT HOME AND MY STRUGGLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES I
FOUND MYSELF ABOUT. A ROOF OVER
MY HEAD MY FIRST DAY IN LA OUR
JAIL TO THE MISSION AND INTEL'S
THE VERSE. A BAY BUT WHEN I GOT
THERE I WAS TOO LATE SO I HAD TO
SLEEP IN MY CAR ABOUT THE ONE
CHAIN FREE. I UP HAVING TO LIVE
OUT MY CAR FLOOD TIME IT BECAUSE
I A LITTLE THE L. REGION. I
FOUND MYSELF CUSTOM CONFUSE
ABOUT BROUGH IN DOWN. NOT ONLY
WAS I KNOW TO THE- AREA BUT I
WASN'T STANDING BY I. HAVE BEEN
SCRATCHED ABOUT HOME. AND HAVING
. VERY LITTLE MY NAY. FOR THE
TWO I RECEIVED FIRST PARTY TO. I
WAS PARTNER FOR OF Y. SEVERAL
OTHER I'M NOT WITH SEVERAL OTHER
CAR. I HAD GO INTO WRITE A FIVE
FOR STREET AND FOR. AND WHEN I.
SKEWS ME CAME OUT THERE WAS
ALREADY A TICKET ON CAR I
REMEMBER I WAS THE ONLY BY CLUB
TEN MINUTES. OVER THE COURSE OF
THA STEP WEEKS TRIED MY TO
FOLLOW ALL THE SWEET SIGNS BUT
IS LESS. SPRING DIFFICULT WITH
NEW BEING. FROM ALL THERE DAY
THE WEEK. AND INCLUDING MY ST
DESTINY ANSWER. OVER THE COURSE
OF- A FEW MONTHS ARE THERE I WAS
GIVEN FIVE CUPS PARKING.
FORTUNATELY THE NAY THIS NEW MY
FOR TICKET. BUT I WILL FORCED TO
COMPETE YOUR NEARLY STARTED. FOR
THE ROOM FOR OF. TICKET FOR THE
FOR FAR AFTER. AT SOME WHO WERE
. WAS SCHOOL POINTS VALUE USED.
IT IS THE- TASK TO FOCUS OR ANY
ELSE. FOR COMPLETING THE CAN.
SERVICE REQUIREMENT WAS.
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO MY MEDICAL
CONDITION. I WAS TO WORK AT THE
BAR SOONER IN DOWNTOWN ALSO. I
WAS REQUIRED TO WORK IN DINER
MAINTAINING PAY WATCH BOB
STATURE. NUMBER OF WEAPONS
TRAINING AT ALL. BECAUSE I WAS
RELEASED. AND I HAD BACKING BUT
I HAVE DO MY JOB THE PROBLEM GO
BACK TO COURT NOT TO BE BOUGHT
BY- I WAS REQUIRED. TO SHORTFALL
WEEK THROUGH FOR SEVEN THIRTY A.
TO FOUR PM THE STATE. ALL OF
LARA FOR SEVERAL HOURS JUST BE
PROGRAM LIKE YOUR BE CAL. ADD A
PRO BACKED ONE DAY IS BEING
POLLS IN AB. EIGHTY FIVE. IN A
BILLABLE AND OFFERED OF THE- AT
THE TIME IT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
ME TO FOCUS ON MY NEEDS AND I'D
IN SUCH. AND HOW. YOUR HOME.
WHAT LITTLE MONEY A PARKING
TICKET BEGIN IN THE BLACK MOVING
HUNDRED PROBLEMS YOUR A SPECIAL
YOU CAN BRING AN END ON MEETINGS
LIKE. AND HOUSING. IT'S WRONG TO
COMMITTEE TO FINISHER. THANK YOU
ABA YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT BEING
SAID I LIKE TO THANK YOU THE
HELP- THAT ARE THAT ARE YOU THAT
YOU GIVEN THE TODAY IN ORDER TO
GET MY SPEECH AND URGED JUST ON
THIS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU VERY
VERY VERY AND- STATE. A NECK
WITNESS. I AM PLUGINS- I'M-
REPRESENTING LOSS- LIVE
EXPERIENCE ADVISORY BOARD AND-
OVER TEN YEARS OF MY EXPERIENCE
AS WELL AS A HOMELESS PERSON-
WHEN I FIRST BECAME ALMOST. ME
AND MY HUSBAND- LIVED IN MY FORD
EXPLORER- ALTHOUGH WE HAD
HANDICAPPED PLACARDS DUCT TAPED
TO THE FRONT WINDSHIELD- THEY
STILL WANNA STICK IT'S- PERFORMS
TO OUR PARKING YOUR PARKING AND
IT DIDN'T MATTER THAT I HAVE TO
PLACARD THERE- THE TICKET'S
MULTIPLIED- I APPEAL TO THE
PARKING BUREAU- THEY TOLD ME IT
WAS BASICALLY MY WORD AGAINST
THE WORD OF THE OFFICER- AND THE
MOMENT THAT YOU'LL LOSE EVERY
TIME AN IDEA SO THEY CONTINUE TO
WRITE THE TICKET- THE FIRST
TIME- MY- MY FAMILY INTO PAYING
THEM OFF. BECAUSE THEY WERE
THREATENING TO IMPOUND THE
VEHICLE. THE SECOND TIME IT WAS
IMPOUNDED- FOR THE PER TIME WE
WERE NEARLY ALL THE STREET- ME
LOS THE SHELF THAT WE- AND OUR
BILL. ARE CLOSE OUR FOOD OUR
MONEY. IMPORTANT IDENTIFICATION
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR HOPE-
I'VE BEEN HOPING TO SELL THE
TRUCK AND USE THE MONEY FOR A
DOWN PAYMENT ON THE SMALL ROOM
SOMEWHERE- NOW EXPOSED
COMPLETELY DEVELOPMENTS- OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS- I HAD
SEVERAL TRAGEDIES BEFALL ME- I
HAD TO ONE WEEK BOUTS OF
PNEUMONIA- I WAS STABBED ONE
NIGHT WHILE SLEEPING ON THE
STREET- AND SOMEONE. ALSO
STABBED MY- MY HUSBAND WHEN I
BUT HE WAS SLEEPING IN ANOTHER
YEAR- ALL OF THESE TRAGEDIES
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED IF WE
HADN'T HAD TO WORRY ABOUT THE
BURDEN OF THE PARKING TICKETS
YOU CAN HELD ONTO A VEHICLE AND
MOST MORE PARTLY BECAUSE OF
ACTED IT HOMELESSNESS MUCH
SOONER THAN WE DID. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW WE HAVE
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. NO WE
HAVE NO REGISTER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO NOW WILL GO TO THE
ROOM TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THE HEARING ROOM WISHING T
TECHNO TESTIFY FOR OR AGAINST.
THE BILL. I DON'T SEE ANYBODY SO
CAN WE PLEASE GO TO THE- I DO
SEE SOMEONE SO COME ON UP IF
YOU'RE HERE TO FOR. AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THIS WOULD BE THE
TIME TO GET IN LINE IN THE
SEARCHES WILL HELP YOU IN AGAIN
FOR THIS PART OF THE TESTIMONY
IT'S JUST NAME. ORGANIZATION
WHETHER YOU'RE FOR OR AGAINST
THE LEGISLATION. JACQUELINE
AMERICANA HALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. A CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO
EVERYONE- DONNA KING ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES SERVICES HOME
SUPPORT LOS ANGELES HOME WITH
THIS SERVICE THE FORTY OFTEN
NORTH LAW FIRM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY
OPERATOR LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES FOR OR
AGAINST AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE FOR OR AGAINST AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
PERSPECTIVES OF THE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON SHARE MY NAME IS ANNA
JOHNSON WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE THAT WE
REPRESENT TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
OF EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS.
INCLUDING COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
MANY OF THEM- DO RELY ON THEIR
VEHICLES DURING TIMES OF
TRANSITION OR HARDSHIP AND WE
ARE CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THE NEXT SCORE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU KATHY
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND PRINT AND ARE
HEARTENED TO SEE A STATE WIDE
SOLUTION THAT IS STRONGER THAN
LOCAL EXISTING PROGRAMS AND DOES
NOT HAVE A FORCED LABOR AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE REQUIREMENT.
THANK YOU. EXTERNAL LINE NUMBER
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PRISCILLA CAN OFTEN BE HAVE A
LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI WE DO NOT A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE FIELD FOR
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
TOWARD JUST CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL MAY UNINTENTIONALLY
UNDERMINE THE COMMUNITY
ASSISTANT- PARKING PROGRAM WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS-
COMMITTEE WORKING WITH US AS WE
WANT TO THE GROUND BY THIS
PROGRAM INTO THE CAN CONTINUE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. NEXT CALL
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA
CERVANTES ON BEHALF OF
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT. NEXT IN
LINE NUMBER FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THAT MAY SOUND BOARD BUT
AGAIN MY NAME IS THEODORE PATTEN
OF SHIFTING CORPORATION FOR TO
PROVIDE YOU. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MATTHEW SO I RULING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NOBILITY OF PARKING ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM THE CAR
LETTER CAME IN LATE- WE DO PLAN
ON. EXTENDING SOME MEDICATIONS
TO MEET WITH THE AUTHOR THAT'S
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND- THE
SPONSORS OF HIS BILL TO DISCUSS
OUR CONCERNS I'M WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH JUST A MOMENT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. NOT APPLICATION FOR
ELIGIBILITY WHICH IS ONE OF OUR
FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS- THEN WE
ALSO JUST WANT RECOGNIZED THAT
THIS MUTUAL PROBLEM AND ARE%
WILLING TO SIT DOWN AND THEN
MARKET OUT BUT- FOR THE TIME
BEING AT THE BILL READ IN PRINT
CURRENTLY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
REMOVING HARD TO PAY FOR THE
ONLY TOOL WE HAVE TO INSURE
COMPLIANCE. PARKING BALLS THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
MARK LOOKS OF A TRUMP STREETS
FOR ALL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. NUMBER LINE NUMBER
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES YES CRITICAL S.
FANTASTIC- INTERLUDES
NORTHWESTWARD- NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU. ENSURE PERCENT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
BEFORE I GO TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS I DO WANT TO VERIFY
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT YOU'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ABSOLUTELY OKAY THANK
YOU. WITH T
KALRA REBOILERED BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHORS AND BRIAN. GOT HEY
GIPSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING HIS BILL OF FORD I AM A
CO AUTHOR OR IN MY JOINED ONE OF
THEM I'M SUPPORT IN THE BILL AND
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT AGAIN
WE BELIEV THIS IS A THOUGHTFUL
MEASURE BECAUSE AGAIN WE LOOK AT
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WHICH I- IT
I DON'T KNOW IF I STILL HAVE THE
DISTINCTION OF BEING THE ONLY
MEMBER OF AT LEAST IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHO'S BEEN AND I WOULD
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS BUT I DO
AND I DO THIS FOR A PARTICULAR
REASON SO THAT WE CAN ONE CREATE
POLICIES THAT PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE- WHO HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT FORGOTTEN AND LEFT
FOR DEAD- AND WE WANT TO STAND
UP FOR THEM WE THINK THAT THIS
IS A- ABSOLUTE. THOUGHTFUL
MEASURE- THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY
GOOD SENSE- WEEK- AS THE AUTHORS
ALREADY ARTICULATED- WE LOSE
MONEY BY TRYING TO GO AFTER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO MEANS OF
THE WAY TO GET THEM GET
THEMSELVES BACK ON THEIR FEET
AND ALSO AS A WAY FOR US TO BE
ONE SHOWING SENSITIVITY- FOR
INDIVIDUALS SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THIS BILL COME
BEFORE US ON THE FLOOR SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROLE WORD THANK
YOU I WANT TO TAKE THE OFFER FOR
BRING THIS FOR AS WELL I KNOW
SOMEBODY THAT HAS I'M LIKE ME
WORK REALLY REALLY CLOSELY TO
KIND OF UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES
THAT MANY ON HOUSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE EXPERIENCING WHAT IS FAIR-
TRY TO USE- ARE OPPORTUNITIES
HERE IS LEGISLATORS TO REALLY
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD CLEAR
THE DECK OUT- FOR A LOT OF
THOSE- PASTIME FRACTIONS THAT
ARE OTHERWISE- DRAGGING DOWN
THERE- THEIR THEIR PATHWAYS FOR
SUCCESS SO I THINK THIS IS
REALLY HELPFUL TO THAT AND- THAT
SAID I THINK THAT THERE'S ALSO
AN OPPORTUNITY GLIDER ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AND
ANALYSES AGAIN ON THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WHICH I SAID ON THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CITIES LOS
ANGELES BEING ONE OF THEM IF YOU
I'M WRONG I'M BECAUSE I DEALT
WITH THIS IN SAN DIEGO THAT WORK
ON VEHICLE HABITATION QUESTIONS
AND I WANT TO APPLAUD THE LOS
ANGELES CITY COUNCIL FOR TRYING
TO SET UP ONE BOTH OPPORTUNITIES
FOR C. PARKING BUT ALSO LOOKING
AT THE ENTIRE MAP OF THE CITY TO
UNDERSTAND. WHERE WE ARE- GOING
TO EXEMPTS- TAKE- AT ALL BECAUSE
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE SOMEWHERE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO- I'M FORCING ME
TO HAVE A HOUSE THE MOMENT THAT
ARE. PLEASE AND SO I WONDER IF
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD IF THERE'S SOME
SORT OF- OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
ENCOURAGE CITIES TO REALLY LOOK
AT THAT MODEL AS WELL- IF THERE
IS. SOME SORT OF A- A GIVE AND
TAKE HERE. THAT WE DO WANT TO BE
ABLE TO CLEAR THE DECK AND HELP
INDIVIDUALS OUT REALLY- RESOLVE
ANY OF THOSE- FINANCIAL AND
LEGAL ISSUES THAT- THAT THERE
ARE CURRENTLY FACING WITH OF THE
MOMENT- BUT ALSO LOOK AT THIS IS
THE- CARE AND STICK OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY ENCOURAGE CITIES. TO
CREATE THOSE SAFE PARKING-
LOCATIONS TO CREATE- AREAS
WITHIN THE CITY WHERE THERE'S
GOING TO BE NO TAKEN ENFORCEMENT
AT THAT AT ALL- I THINK THIS IS
THAT THE KIND. OF IDEA THAT CAN
REALLY SPUR THAT THE
CONVERSATION- IN SAN DIEGO- WE
DID NOT GO AS FAR AS WE SHOULD
HAVE THAT'S WHY I OPPOSE OUR
VEHICLE HABITATION ORDINANCE-
BECAUSE IT REALLY DIDN'T. OFFER
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES OUTSIDE OF
DESIGNATED. PARKING AREAS. WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD BE- I. WOULD NOT
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT GETTING A
TAKE IN THE FIRST PLACE WE'RE
STILL ADDING A BURDEN WHERE THEY
HAVE TO GO GET THIS CLEARED OUT
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND- ALSO. I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS
REALLY TRYING TO EASE THOSE
BURDENS. AND REALLY HELP PEOPLE
BACK ON TO A SUCCESSFUL PATHWAY
IT FASTER- SO MY WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THAT THAT GOING FOR NOT
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU. AS
YOU FOR THIS BILL AND I THINK
YOU FOR BRINGING A FOREIGN. YES
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU WERE. I AM
A STRONG SUPPORTER THIS BILL I
THINK IT MAKES GREAT SENSE IT
HAS. SOME CHECKS AND BALANCES
CONTAINED. IN THE PROVISIONS.
AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO.
SEEING IT TO WORK SUCCESSFULLY I
HOPE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER DALY. ANYONE ELSE. SEEING
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOUR- YOUR COMMENTS- AND SUPPORT
. A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO I HELPED
MY OLDER BROTHER BEAU BLACK CAR
- LIKE ME HE WAS ADOPTED AS A
CHILD BUT HE RE ENTERED THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AS A
TEENAGER. AND HE WAS ON HOUSE
REPAIR TIME HE LIVED IN THAT CAR
THAT I HELPED HIM GET. AND WHEN
HE LOST THAT CAR. HE STARTED
SLEEPING IN PERSHING SQUARE. AND
THAT'S WHEN MENTAL ILLNESS
STARTED CREEPING. THAT'S WHEN.
IT WENT BEYOND POVERTY AND
BECAME. A MORE CUMULATIVE
STRUGGLE. I ANY STRUGGLE FOR A
LONG TIME TO FIND HOUSING HE
SINCE THEN FOUND HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY BUT THAT PERIOD OF
EXITING HOMELESSNESS AS WAS
MENTIONED BY SOME OF OUR
WITNESSES CAN BE EXPEDITED
EXPEDITED IF WE LET PEOPLE KEEP
THE LITTLE ASSETS THAT THEY
HAVE. A VEHICLE BEING ONE OF
THEM SO THANK YOU FOR HEARINGS
GOING TO RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
. THANK YOU WELL THE BEST BILLS
COME OUT OF PEOPLE'S LIVED
EXPERIENCES AND THE EXPERIENCES
THEY WITNESS AROUND THEM. AND
YOUR PASSION FOR THE SUBJECT IN
THIS BILL ARE EVIDENT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR-
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US TO
MAKE IT THE BEST BILL THAT WE
KNOW HOW TO TRY TO MAKE. AND I
WOULD ALSO REQUEST TO BE ASKED
AS ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. DO PASSED AS
AMENDED HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FRIEDMAN. AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY
AYE DAVIES. GIPSON HI GIPSON I
KALRA KALRA I LI LI HI MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
O'DONNELL. WARD WARD I WICKS.
NINE ZERO. THANK YOU NINE ZERO
THE BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN AS WE WILL FOR THE
REST OF THE BILLS THAT WE HEAR
MORE NOW MOVING TO AB TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARILLO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREE-
YOU MAY. BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY THANK YOU.
BOTH AVAIL I GUESS. IT WOULD
MOTION THE SECOND C. MAY PROCEED. SO I WOULD YOU TO PUSH THE
BUTTON. CHECK ONE TWO ALL RIGHT
. WE START AGAIN THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE EXPEDIENCY I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
A BILL THAT WOULD INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY OF DATA IN THE PORT
DRAYAGE INDUSTRY AMID COVERED
NINETEEN WE HAVE SEEN SUPPLY
CHAIN DELAYS HIGHLIGHT THE
STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN EFFICIENT
GOODS MOVEMENT AT OUR NATION'S
PORTS. AND WHILE COVE IT WAS
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
SHUTDOWNS AROUND THE WORLD
WIDESPREAD MISS CLASSIFICATION
OF TRUCK DRIVERS CONTRIBUTED TO
A SHORTAGE OF DRIVERS AND LESS
EFFICIENT PORT OPERATIONS IN
RESPONSE TO THIS CRISIS THE
PORTS ARE OUR GATEWAY TO THE
WORLD IN A CRITICAL AND CRITICAL
TO THE FLOW OF GOODS IN THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY. PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN WILL
INVEST BILLIONS IN MODERNIZING
PORTS IN HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
CALLED FOR INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND DATA COLLECTION
TO IMPROVE EFFICIENCY AND
IDENTIFY BOTTLENECKS. MEMBERS
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES HAS
RANKED AS THE NUMBER ONE
CONTAINER PORT IN THE UNITED
STATES SINCE TWO THOUSAND. THIS
IS RIGHT IN MY OWN BACKYARD THIS
TRANSLATES TO MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
TRUCKS MOVING FROM THE PORT OF
LA AND ALSO THE PART OF LONG
BEACH THE PORT OF OAKLAND. BUT
THE PACIFIC LEE TO L. A. COUNTY
TO THE INLAND EMPIRE WAREHOUSES
AND ALONG THE WAY PAST MY
DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES. THE TO
THE FIVE THE TEN THE ONE A ONE
THE ONE TEN THE ONE THIRTY FOUR
AND THE SEVEN TEN FREEWAYS.
LABRANG COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR DECADES TO RAISE
STANDARDS AT THE PORTS FROM
REDUCING EMISSIONS TO CRACKING
DOWN. ON MISS CLASSIFICATION. I
AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY TO COLLECT AND
CONSOLIDATE SPECIFIED DATA
RELATED TO THE GOODS MOVEMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION SUPPLY CHAIN. AND
WILL REQUIRE THE AGENCY TO MAKE
THIS DATA PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON
ITS WEBSITE. THIS WORK HAS BEEN.
IN A POWERFUL PARTNERSHIP OF
LABOR. ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVOCATES UNITED TO PUSH FOR
CLEAN AND SAFE PORTS. THERE HAVE
BEEN VARIOUS EFFORTS TO HELP
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS HOWEVER
THE WORK IS CHALLENGING BECAUSE
DATA ON THE PORT DRAYAGE
INDUSTRY IS SPREAD ACROSS.
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES AND ON
MULTIPLE DATABASES. THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO FILL IN SOME OF
THOSE GAPS AND CREATE A MUCH
NEEDED STANDARD DATA COLLECTION
THAT BE THAT CAN BE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE IN ONE PLACE. WE HAVE
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION OVER THE CONCERNS.
AND THEY HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
FIND A REASONABLE PATH FORWARD
TO TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE IS RUN
IT UP PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR. AND SECRETARY TREASURER
OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE NINE
EIGHT AND SAM APPEL WITH THE
BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE. THANK YOU
AND I'M GONNA BE PASSED THE
GAVEL TO MR FONG BECAUSE I HAVE
TO GO PERCENT OF BILL. THANK I
WILL START WITH RON AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO SAM THAT'S OKAY.
OPERATOR PLEASE PROCEED MMHM.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HONORARY PRESIDENT IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR AND SECRETARY CHENEY OF
CHANGES UP OF THE NINETY SIX HOW
THE SPONSOR AB TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
MY UNION AND FIGHTING TO IMPROVE
CONDITIONS AT THE COURTS FAR TOO
MANY OF THESE IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ARE MISCLASSIFIED AND FORCED TO
BUSINESS WITHOUT HAVING ANY
CONTROL OF THEIR OWN RATES ARE
WORKING CONDITIONS USA TODAY
COMPARED. IT TO INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE. THE CONDITIONS A
DIRECT IMPACT ON BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE PORTS
WHEN DRIVERS HAVE TO BEAR THE
CONSTANT CLEAN TRUCK UPGRADES.
THERE IS A LOWER COMPLIANCE RATE
AND- AND POLLUTING TRUCKS
CONTINUE TO CAUSE ASTHMA CANCER
AND OTHER HEALTH PROBLEMS FOR
FAMILIES LIVING NEXT TO THE
PORTS. WE'VE HEARD A LOT LATELY
ABOUT SUPPLY CHAIN DELAYS
CONDITIONS AT THE COURTS DON'T
JUST IMPACT DRIVERS AND
COMMUNITIES. THEY IMPACT OUR
ENTIRE ECONOMY WE NEED BETTER
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO'S GOING IN
AND OUT OF OUR PORTS AND HOW TO
MAKE THE SYSTEM MORE EFFICIENT
SAFER. AND MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN IS
AN AIRLINE FOCUS REMEDY IT CALLS
ON COURTS TO COLLECT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ASKED THE-
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO COMPILE
DATA. FROM SEVERAL STATE
AGENCIES TO CREATE ONE CENTURY
LANDING PLACE THIS WILL ALLOW
POLICYMAKERS AND ADVOCATES TO
FIND THE BEST SOLUTIONS FOR
SAFER AND CLEANER PORTS. WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE PORT SHOULD
MATTER TO ALL OF US FROM
IMMIGRANT DRIVERS LEASING BE
GREAT YOU NAY CANNOT AFFORD TO.
SINGLE MOTHERS TRYING TO PROTECT
YOUR CHILDREN FROM EMISSIONS.
AND POOR COMMUNITIES OUR
COMMUNITY. EDITOR DESERVE BETTER
. BEYOND THAT ARE GOING ECONOMY
KANEMI REALIZE ON A POOR INTO.
IS ESSENTIAL TO GOOD. DECISION
MAY WE ARE PROUD TO A B. TWO
FIFTY SEVEN AND WE COMMAND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR
BEING A CHAMPION ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK
YOU. SAM YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FAMILY HELLO CALIFORNIA THE
MANAGER FOR BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE
WHICH IS AN ALLIANCE THE STATE
ORGANIZATIONS
ONE OF THE MOST POLLUTING
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA AND ONE
WITH PERHAPS THE MOST
EXPLOITATIVE WORKING CONDITIONS
AS TO ADD DETAIL BY- REASON THAT
THE CRITICAL SECTOR OF FOCUS FOR
THE LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE MOVEMENT
IN OUR STATE. LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED THE NUMBER OF BILLS TO
CLEAN UP THE SECTOR AND REDUCE
THE INSIDIOUS PRACTICE SUBMIT
CLASSIFICATION. DESPERATE THAT
INCLUDED EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT AND TODAY WE TURNED AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN. DESPITE THE
EFFORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE MAKE
CLASSIFICATION REMAINS
INCREDIBLY CRISP IT DIDN'T
BUSINESS STRATEGY AND TRUCKING
THAT NOT ONLY EXPLOITS TRUCK
DRIVERS BUT ALSO PUT HUGE
BARRIERS IN THE WAY TO GO TO
GETTING CLEANER TRUCKS ON THE
ROAD. THE LEGISLATURE IS
ATTACKED THIS PROBLEM FROM ALL
ANGLES BUT OUR TRUCK DRIVERS AND
DJ COMMUNITIES NEED MORE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION HERE. BECAUSE
COMPANIES OFFLOAD COSTS OF
OPERATIONS ON TO DRIVERS
MISCLASSIFIED CONTRACTORS ARE
FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR STATEMENT
EMISSIONS. RULES THAN OTHER
FLEET. OUR DATA BEARS THIS OUT
AND- AHEAD THEIR OWN MISSION TRY
IS THE TO BE SO MUCH FOR. WITH
MATH CLASS TO IN THE WAY AT
EVERY. AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN IST
SO CRITICAL BECAUSE CURRENTLY WE
DON'T HAVE THE DATA WE NEED
ADVOCATES AND THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND THE FULL SCOPE OF
TRUCKING OPERATIONS. DATA CENTER
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS AGENCIES AND
WE CAN'T SEE HOW THE INDUSTRY AS
A WHOLE OPERATE. EVEN CARBS
STAFF HAVEN'T EEN ABLE TO
ASSEMBLE A FULL PICTURE OF THIS
DATA AND ONGOING TRUCKING RULE
MAKING THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING.
GOVERNING GOVERNING PROCESS
THESE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
TRANSPARENCY AND ULTIMATELY
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE LAWS THAT
THAT LEGISLATORS PASSED. I
PERSONALLY PUBLISHED REPORTS ON
THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING INDUSTRY
GROUND PUBLIC RECORD REQUESTS
AND NO THE X. I KNOW THAT AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN WILL ANSWER
CRITICAL QUESTIONS SO CRITICAL
DATA HOLES AND INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ONGOING
RULEMAKINGS AND PREVIOUSLY
ENACTED LAWS. PLEASE CONTINUE
THE LEGISLATURE LEGACY OF
CLIMATE ACTION THAT SUPPORTS OUR
STATE'S MOST EXPLOITED WORKERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO
AND- TO OPPOSITION. I THINK WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
AND HARBOR TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
SO ODD. IN PERSON A MEASURE MOTA
AND WE HAVE ON THE PHONE MATT A
STRAP FROM THE HARBOR TRUCKING
SO WE'LL START WITH CHRIS AND
WE'LL GO TO MACRI'S THE RECEIPT.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIR FONG AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CHRISTMAS
WITH CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. A CTA MUST
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN AT THIS TIME. AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
CAL STUDY CONTINUOUSLY GATHER
AND PUBLISH INFORMATION FROM
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AT LEAST TEN
PORT AUTHORITIES. ANNELIES FIVE
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING CARB
OSHA ET DE D. LSE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. I ENCOMPASSING EIGHT
REGULATORY DATABASES AT LEAST
FIVE GRAND LOAN PROGRAMS IN THE
CREATION OF A NEW DATA GATHERING
REPORTING OBLIGATION FOR THE TEN
SEAPORTS. WELL THE STATED GOAL
OF AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN IS TO
INFORM SMARTER POLICY AND
IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
THE RULES CITED IN THIS BILL
ALREADY EXTENSIVELY ENFORCED FOR
EXAMPLE EXISTING VEHICLE CODE
REQUIRES COMPLIANCE WITH CARBS
DRAYAGE TRUCK RULE IN INSPECTION
AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. AS A
CONDITION OF DMV REGISTRATION.
WAGE AND HOUR LAWS ARE ENFORCED
BY THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
BUREAU FIELD ENFORCEMENT.
CLAIMANTS CAN ADDITIONALLY BRING
WAGE CLAIMS THE LABOR COMMISSION
FIELD OFFICES PORT TRUCKING
COMPANIES WHO HAVE UNPAID WAGE
CLAIMS ARE PUBLISHED ON THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S WEBSITE.
AND CUSTOMERS OF THESE COMPANIES
ARE SUBJECT TO JOINT LIABILITY
FOR PROSPECTIVE WAGE CLAIMS.
FINALLY AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
PROPOSES TO SHIFT THE COSTS IN
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN OF
GATHERING INFORMATION THAT THE
SPONSORS COULD OTHERWISE ARE
ALREADY OBTAINED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT TO
THE TAXPAYERS A CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THE COST OF THE STATE
TOGETHER AND WILL LIKELY BE HIGH
IN WILL TAKE FUNDS THAT COULD
OTHERWISE BE SPENT ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE GRANTS. FOR
MORE RESOURCES FOR ENFORCEMENT
THE QUESTION SHOULD BE WHAT
BENEFIT WILL AB TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN CRATE THAT IS NOT
OTHERWISE PROVIDED FOR. BY
EXISTING LAW REGULATION AND
ENFORCEMENT. FINALLY. WE LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
FOR REACHING HOW TO DISK THIS
BILL IN OF THIS HERE. C. TO A-
THE CONTINUED WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH LABOR IN THE
AUTHOR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THIS BILL FURTHER AS
IT MOVES THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A MISTER CHAPMAN ARE
YOU ON THE PHONE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU SHARE FARMING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
AFTERNOON ON AB TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN. BUT IT IS NOT SHOT BY IN
THE CEO OF THE HARBOR TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST HARBOR DURING SPECIFIC
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND ARE BASED HERE IN
THE GREAT CITY CALIFORNIA.
SALINAS ARE CALLED OF THE
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION
EXPRESSED HER DISPLEASURE TIME
AGO WE MUST ALSO. AB TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN. WE CAN APPRECIATE
THE NEED FOR ROBUST DATA SHARING
MEASURES IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
ISN'T CLEAR HOW THIS MAGIC
MEASURE FURTHER ENHANCED SUPPLY
CHAIN EFFICIENCY. IN ITS CURRENT
FORM THE BILL IS NOT A FOCUS ON
EFFICIENCY IMPROVEMENTS AND
ENHANCEMENTS. IT REALLY CREATES
ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
FROM ATTENDING CALIFORNIA PORTS.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. LARGE
EUROPEAN WE COLLECT INTO DATA
FROM. DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE DISCOVERABLE
THROUGH PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST. HE'S REQUIREMENTS TO
COME AT A TIME WHEN AGENCY
IMPORT RESOURCES ARE GREATLY
NEEDED TO TACKLE AND IMPLEMENT
ACTIONABLE MATTERS MEASURES TO
ENHANCE MOBILITY SAFETY AND THE
LOST CITY WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPLY CHAIN. FURTHERMORE AS YOU
FORGIVE CTA RULES CITED IN AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN ARE ALREADY
EXTENSIVELY ENFORCED. SO IT
ISN'T CLEAR WHAT BENEFITING AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN WOULD CREATE
THAT IS NOT ALREADY IN CURRENT
LAW AND HAS READILY AVAILABLE
DATA. IS FOR THESE REASONS WHY
WE MUST OPPOSE AB TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN HOWEVER WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AND I
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. I THINK
IT WAS DROPPED- WE WILL NOW GO
TO YOU IN PERSON TESTS HAVE BEEN
IN PERSON- IN ANY OF ANY
INDIVIDUALS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WANT TO COME FORWARD AND-
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT PLEASE DO
SO NOW. CENA AND ANYONE. HERE IN
THE ROOM THAT WANT TO COME
FORWARD AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION. TO NONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONES. OPERATOR
AT ANY ONE THAT WANTS TO- BEGIN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN A PLEASE PROCEED.
Q. ONE CAN MEASURE OF YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB TWO
ZERO FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BRING YOUR
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE LINENUMBER FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHANG MEMBERS SHANGO SPENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD- THIS IS SANTIAGO
RODRIGUEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPELL. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER A LOT OF ANY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JIM SMITH WITH TEAMSTERS
LOCAL THREE NINETY SIX IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NEXT TO THE
LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DEREK
ROBINSON I'M WITH THE FEDERAL
POLICY INITIATIVES AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEDIA THE NEEDS
ON THE HELP OF THE WAREHOUSE
LOCAL RESEARCH CENTRE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
. OVERLIE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MICHAEL THE MOST WITH THE LOS
ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR YOU ECONOMY
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
WELL LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS NAOMI
STEINFELD A MEMBER OF CLERGY AND
LAITY UNITED FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN. AT THIS TIME SHOPPERS WE HAVE
NOBODY ELSE IN Q. I THINK I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY MEMBERS. HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
. SEEING NONE I DO HAVE A
QUESTION- TO THE OPPOSITION I
MAYBE I'LL JUST REFER REFERENCE
OR SPEAK TO OF ASSET TO- THE
COUPLE TICKETS ADDITION THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF FOCUS ON THE
SUPPLY CHAIN- CAN YOU DELVE A
LITTLE DEEPER IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL ON
HOW- AFFECTS THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES RIGHT NOW.
AND HOW WE HAD HOW THIS WOULD
IMPACT IN A DAILY BASIS-
CERTAINLY THANK YOU TEAR FONG-
SO IT YEAH WITH RESPECT TO THE
DATA GATHERING EFFORTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE HARBOR
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION REFERRED
TO- THERE BEEN ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS FOR MANY YEARS NOW.
ABOUT TRYING TO GET DIFFERENT-
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTS OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN MEANING TRUCKERS
OCEAN CARRIERS THE PARTS
THEMSELVES. TO SHARE BETTER
OPERATIONAL INFORMATION- IF YOU
CAN KNOW WHEN- A PARTICULAR
CONTAINERS GOING TO ARRIVE IN
THE PORT ON A PARTICULAR DAY. IT
WILL. INCREASE EVERYBODY'S
ABILITY TO PLAN FOR THAT.
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW THAT THEY
NEEDED LABOR WORK WHAT MAY NEED
TO BE. A BETTER THE WHITE HOUSE
IS SUPPORTING A DATA SHARING
INITIATIVE WITHIN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN SO THIS IS AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION. I THINK OUR CONCERN
HERE IS REALLY- THE COST OF
COLLATING. THESE VARIOUS DATA
POINTS THAT ALREADY IN EXISTENCE
FROM THESE DIFFERENT REGULATORY
PROGRAMS AND GRANT INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS INTO ONE PLACE WOULD
COME AT A SIGNIFICANT COST THAT
AT YOU KNOW AT THIS PARTICULAR
TIME. WE'RE LOOKING AT A
TRANSITION AS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WERE LOOKING AT TRYING
TO GET TRUCKERS INTO THE SUPPLY
CHAIN WE WOULD RATHER HAVE
RESOURCES GO TOWARDS THOSE
EFFORTS- YOU KNOW IN A
PRODUCTIVE WAY. RATHER THAN JUST
SPENDING MONEY FOR THE SAKE OF
DOING IT ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT- ALLOWS FOR
THESE THESE DOCUMENTS TO BE
DISCOVERED BY THE SPONSORS. AND
MIKE A QUICK FOLLOW UP AND- I
EITHER MR TRUMP OR MISHMAR YOU
CAN ANSWER THIS QUESTION BUT OF
THAT THE AMOUNT OF TRUCKERS THAT
ARE- GOING INTO THE PORTS HOW
MANY ARE. ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. WHAT WHAT
PERCENTAGE SO NATIONALLY- THE
PROPORTION OF INDEPENDENT
TRUCKERS TO COMPANY DRIVERS IS
ROUGHLY 90% COMPANY DRIVERS TO
TEN PERCENT- OWNER OPERATORS AND
I'VE HEARD STATISTICS AT THE
PORT THAT ARE ROUGHLY THIRTY
PERCENT. INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS
THE 70% A COMPANY DRIVERS. A
MISTER SHOP DID YOU WANT TO-
PROVIDE ANYMORE CONTEXT. I KNOW
HE'S ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN GERMAN FONG I AM
ACTUALLY AND YOU KNOW AND YOU
CAN ECHOING SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT THAT CHRISTENDOM HERE TO
HEAR WHAT WERE WE ARE IN. A
UNIQUE POSITION- WITH A DIVERSE
WORKFORCE BOTH LEADERS SUPPORTED
BY COMPANY EMPLOYEES DRIVERS
TEAMSTER DRIVERS AS WELL AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD UNDERSTANDING
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE. AREN'T PROPOSED. RATHER THAN
AROUND HORIZON HERE FROM THE
SOME OF THE STANDARDS IT REALLY
IS- I NEED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE AS MANY
RESOURCES AS POSSIBLE TO ASSIST
ALL COMPANIES. IN COMPLYING WITH
THE RULES SO- WHILE THE
PROPORTION OF EMPLOYEES VERSUS
OUR OPERATORS CAN FLUCTUATE IT
IS RELATIVELY CONSISTENT WITH
POINT TOP WITH WHAT MR
STRUGGLING TO. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS-
WITHOUT THE CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THE DATA IS ALREADY BEING
COLLECTED AND AS THE OPPOSITION
STATED. IT'S COLLECTED IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT PLACES IN
AN EFFORT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AT ONE
PORTAL TO A BIT BE ABLE TO GET.
DATA TO BE ABLE TO INFORMED OUR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE POLICY THAT HELPS
WORKERS THAT HELPS THE PORTS
THAT HELPS OUR ECONOMY THAT
HELPS OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
ALL OF THIS IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE YES BUT INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT TO FIND. AND SO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WE NEED TO CREATE
THE TECHNOLOGY NECESSARY FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO FIND THIS
INFORMATION QUICKLY WHICH WAS
ALSO ARTICULATED BY THE
OPPOSITION. SO I'M NOT SURE
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DEBATING HERE
BECAUSE THIS IS A POLICY
COMMITTEE TRANSPORTATION DEALS
WITH POLICY. ANYTHING RELATED TO
FISCAL IMPACT CAN BE DEBATED IN
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH WOULD BE
THE NEXT STEP AND SO I RECEBER
SPEC FULLY I REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE AYE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
THAT WE DON'T. WE DON'T DEPEND
ON THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST TO MAKE POLICY DECISIONS
THEY SHOULD ALL BE AVAILABLE FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND. AND
MAKE GOOD POLICY AND SO
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. MISTER CHAIR THE
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR OF IT
OCCURRED TO ME THAT TO. IT IS AN
ODD. DISCUSSION FOR THE REASONS
YOU STATED- ON THE OTHER HAND-
AS ANYONE APPROACHED THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT I MEAN IT'S
NOT A HUGE TECHNOLOGICAL FEAT
ISN'T TO CONSOLIDATE THE DATA
AND HAVE. A SINGLE FORMAT AND
HAS ANYONE APPROACHED THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT DOING SO
THAT A BILL WOULD NOT BE
NECESSARY. IT CERTAINLY UP A
PROCESS THAT WE CAN TRY TO DO
THE- POLICY APPROACH IS THAT SO
IT'S IN STATUTE AND NO MATTER
WHO IS IN CHARGE OR WHO IS
GOVERNOR WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY GO. WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE THE
NECESSARY TECHNOLOGY AND TOOLS
SO THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE IT IN
ONE PLACE AND GET ALL THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO ONLINE AND
HAVE IT IN ONE SOLID LOCATION.
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY WORTH
EXPLORING I APPRECIATE THAT.
WELL WHEN MR FONG IS GOVERNOR
I'M SURE HE'LL BE A COOPERATIVE
YOU KNOW IT IT. I. YOU JUST PAY
MY HAIR GOES GRAY. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MYSTERY. I THINK
IT IS A DAILY SEEN NO OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THE- BY THE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. AMAP SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YOU PASSED TO LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT FRIEDMAN. FONG
FONG NO BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY HI DALY AYE
DAVIES GIPSON HI GIPSON I KALRA
KALRA I LEE. MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL. WARD
WICKS. SEVEN ONE. SEVEN ONE WILL
KEEP BY THE ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
NOW PURSUE DIFFERENT. TO FILE
ITEM. FOUR A MISTER GAVE BILL AB
TWO THOUSAND.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
. WAS THE BILL I MEAN I MOVED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE TURN
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
BE PRESENTING AB TWO THOUSAND
WHICH WILL PROHIBIT STREET
RACING AND SHOT SIDE SHOWS FROM
OCCURRING IN PARKING LOTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER
VICE CHAIR I KNOW THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT YOU AND THE CHAIR OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
HAVE BEEN LEADERS ON. AS YOU
KNOW OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS
THE CHP HAS REPORTED A NEARLY
3100% SURGE IN EXHIBITION OF
SPEED CITATIONS AND IN THIS LAST
YEAR ALONE THE CHP REPORTED OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND CALLS
INVOLVING EXHIBITION OF SPEED
AND SPEED CONTESTS AND MORE THAN
10% OF THOSE CASES THAT RESULTED
IN CRASHES. ALSO RESULTED IN
FATALITIES AND SO THIS IS A
STREET RACING CHARGES CAN
DEVASTATE FAMILIES CLAIM
INNOCENT LIVES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CREATE SERIOUS
REST FOR ALL INVOLVED AB TWO
THOUSAND EXPANDS THE CRIMES OF
VEHICLE MOTOR EXHIBITION OF
SPEED AND SPEED CONTEST TO
INCLUDE PARKING LOTS AND
HOPEFULLY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO. GIVE MORE TOOLS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO CRACKDOWN
ON ILLEGAL RACING AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT'S HOPEFULLY IT'S
GOING TO SAVE THE LIVES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO OUT WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY ARE FIGHTING ORTIZ. A
STUDENT AND LETELIER LILI
TRUJILLO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF STREET RACING TELLS AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND AN AYE VOTE. I THANK
YOU REST AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO TO THE PHONES THAT WILL
START WITH- FATIMA AND THEN
WE'LL GET ILLEGALLY SO- PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO MY NAME IS FATIMA
OR TO USE I AM CURRENTLY A
STUDENT AT ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY I AM STUDYING. PUBLIC
SERVICE PUBLIC POLICY WITH A
MINOR IN BUSINESS. I'M HERE
TODAY TO ENHANCE THE IMPORTANT
OF THE L. TWO THOUSAND. WHICH I
BELIEVE IS. NOT JUST AN ORDINARY
BUT MANY YOUNG PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY THAT OUR EXPERIENCED
WHAT I HAVE EXPERIENCED. THE HOW
. AB TWO THOUSAND MARKS THAT
SIZE SO THAT MAKES IT THE NATION
OF SHEEP AND LEGAL PARKING LOT
OUR DANGEROUS AND I GREAT
BECAUSE I THAT MIGHT. WITHIN THE
LAW SHE- I HAD NO IDEA OF THE
DANGER THAT THIS HOUSE WOULD
BRING TO MY LIFE AND ALSO THE
CONSEQUENCES THE CONSEQUENCES
THAT WOULD BRING TO ME
AFTERWARDS. STILL MARK TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE. I MY
ONE OF MY FRIENDS. THAT I COULD
NOT BE MY FRIEND ANYMORE HE
BOUGHT ME INTO ONE OF THE FIVE
SHOWS THAT HOURS YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY LIKE NOT KNOWING WHAT
THEY WERE I WAS LIKE OKAY. THIS
IS. COOL AND THEN I WOULD BE
COULD NOT AGREE HAVE CALLED BY
THEIR- YOU KNOW PURPLE THE- AND
CLEANING. NOW CLICK OKAY I'M I
WANT TO SEE THE IS ABOUT. AND
THEN I GOT IN A SOME BE A. AND
THEN NAY GREEN AND I CAR THEN. I
DO HEAR. ON THE COFFEE HERE AND
I HEAR THAT BEFORE I CAN TALK
LET ME OUT OF YOUR CAR BECAUSE-
LOCAL COMMITTEE. AND- I DID AND
I JUST I WOULD BE GOOD PHONE I
NO TIME TO TELL US. LOT OF THE
CAR. RIGHT PINE THAT GOLF AND.
AB ONE RIGHT AWAY FROM THE CALL
AND I WOULD JUST. I WOULD AND I
LOOK AT THE COAST AND THE LOOK
FOR A CLEAN NOW I'VE.
EVEN THEN I COULDN'T LOOK. AT MY
HANDS ARE SHAKING WHY I'M TRYING
TO. BE ON MY PHONE AND LOOK FOR
A FREEWAY. BECAUSE I'M STILL
TRYING TO COMPREHEND EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON. AND NEXT OUT
HIT AND THEN. HAVING QUICKLY PUT
IN THE CAR AND I'M IN SHOCK
BECAUSE I THOUGHT LIKE I KNOW
THIS IS A DANGER. THAT VERY
MOMENT WHEN I WAS LIKE THIS IS A
DANGER AND NOT JUST THE DANGER
NOW I'M GETTING IN TROUBLE WHAT
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN TROUBLE. BY
THE LAW. AND THEN WHEN THAT. A
JUST IT WAS A VERY I OPENED
COMMITTEE. I WAS THIS IS MY THE
CUT PEOPLE OR AREA AND I NEED TO
BE AROUND. SO COULD NOT MOMENT
ON. RELY FIVE. HELLO WHY DID
GOING ON WHAT WHAT I'M MANY
LEVELS I SAT. UP I DON'T I DON'T
TO BE INTERRUPTERS THE STORE I'D
VERY POWER BY IF YOU COULD JUST
IF YOU COULD WRAP UP PLEASE. THE
YES. BUT OVERALL I THINK BILL
CLINTON OF AB TWO AND NOT JUST
THOUGHT BUT JUNK AROUND ME AND
GAVE MATTER. AN INMATE- REALIZE
BEING AWARE. THAT THERE'S OF
EDEN GO PARKING LOT OF. A LOT OF
THE TO PEOPLE LIFE NOW JUST
THEIR BUT ANYWAY AROUND THE AND
IF IT DOES MAKE. THAT COULD
CREATE A PROVIDE EVERYONE AROUND
HOUSE. THANK YOU MUCH FOR THE
MONEY AT THE VERY VERY POWERFUL
TED. WOULDN'T NOW GOES TO THE TO
LITERATURE HERE THESE ARE
DIRECTOR TWO A KILLS. HE'S
PRETTY READY. A DO WE HAVE
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE. OPERATOR
CAN BE FINED MR NOT SHOW LATELY. OKAY WE DID IF YOU ARE ONLINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE
MOMENT. GO AHEAD. HE ALSO I'M
NOT OPEN. NOW OKAY WE DO NOT
SEEM TO HAVE HER ON THE LINE
OKAY WE WILL- WE'LL NOT PROCEED
IF SHE COMES BACK ON WILL WILL
GIVE HER- SOMETIME WILL NOW GO
TO THE OPPOSITION I BELIEVE THE
WE HAVE FREDERICK WILLIAMS NAY
SO YOU- PLEASE PROCEDURE TWO
MINUTES. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS SPREAD WHIMS ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IF
THE- ACCIDENT IS A COLLABORATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. UNIT IN A BAT
POPULATION AB TWO THOUSAND. WITH
THE WITH THE DEMOCRATIC ENGAGING
IN A MOTOR VEHICLE YOU CONTACT
OUR EXHIBITION TO INCLUDE
PARKING FACILITIES. THIS BILL
ONLINE DISPATCH REGARDING THE
HIGHWAYS WITH THE STATURE
REGARDING OFF. STREET PARKING
FACILITY. TO BEGIN OF WHAT THE
ACLU RECOGNIZED THAT HE
CONTACTED BACK TO BEIJING ABOUT
DANGERS INCLUDING YOU. WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT OFF STREET PARKING
FACILITIES AND HIGHWAYS. A LIST
OF THE SAME DANGER TO THE
PUBLIC. CURRENT LAW PROHIBITING
DATING IN MOTOR VEHICLES BE
CONTESTS. FOR EXHIBITION ON THE
HIGHWAY. BOB AND A HIGH GOING TO
STAND ARE MUCH MORE DATED WILL
OF BACKING AT A CERTAIN BUT
COULD CREATEBRAG OR INJURY
GREAT WHAT YOU CAN'T EXHIBITION
OF THE CONCERN PUBLIC HAZARD BUT
HAD TO DO NOT RIDE SAME BOTH
HIGHWAY WOULD BE IMPROVED FOR
THE LEAD ONLINE THE TO DATE THAN
PEOPLE IN ADDITION BECAUSE AND
THAT'S OF ALREADY THE PATIENT
OUT OF A LAW. IF A PERSON. THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT A PRIVILEGE TO
GET AMERICAN DRIVING THE ALREADY
BECOME THE- SO WOW UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR THE BILL WE DO BILL
THAT THE CAN CONNECT TO ADD BOB
CRIME ALREADY DO COVERS BECAUSE
AND ARE DID ALL THE- THANK. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DID I HEAR
LILY ON THE PHONE THE G. DID AIR
VOICE. YES PLEASE PROCEED YES
YES. OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT. YES
MY NAME IS DAVID TO GET POCKET I
AM THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS TO WAIT HE KILLS IN
DECEMBER TWENTY THIRTEEN MY
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
VALENTINA WAS KILLED WHEN A
YOUNG MAN WAS GIVING HIM A RIDE
HOME I THINK REACHING TWO A
STRAIGHT CRASHED. HI NETTED IN
QUESTION RACE MY THAT IT WILL BE
A LIVE. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
THE LEGAL BUT EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS. AT THE SEVENTY WEAPON
. AND TANKS. IT WAS DIRECTING IS
BEING A LEAVE THE EVENT ORDER
WAITER YOUNG PEOPLE ARE BEING
INVITED TO ATTEND THE FACTORS
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT THEY'RE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES IN DANGER AS
YOU HEARD PARTY MONTHS BEFORE.
SOME OF THEM AND THAT THE JURY
KILLED. SO IN OTHER OF MY
DAUGHTER BY THE D'ALESSANDRO AND
THE FINAL TWO WEEKS KILLED I
KNOW MISSED CHUNKS OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TO TELL. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO- ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT
LIKE THIS SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TWO THOUSAND. MISTER MEMBERS
CORY CELLS- ON BEHALF. OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA WATER ABA
WITH TRIPLE A IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM THAT LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PROCEED
FORWARD. C. NINE WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- WE'LL HEAR FROM
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT AB TWO
THOUSAND. OPERATOR PLEASE
PARTICULARLY TENANTS. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF BILL AB TWO
THOUSAND PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO TO
PLACE YOUR LINE INTO Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. THE LINE FIFTY
FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON OTHER COUNTRIES
STRATEGIES CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO THOUSAND THANK YOU FOR.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GERRY DIE
LYNCH I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CONOR LYNCH FOUNDATION AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FAMILIES FOR
SAFE STREETS WHO ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THOUSAND THANK
YOU. MISTER HAIR WE HAVE NO
OTHER OUTLINES IN Q. YOU MAY
PROCEED. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS A BILL BEFORE
US- CERTAINLY AROUND VEHICLE-
WHETHER ITS VEHICLE MANSLAUGHTER
HOMICIDE DRUNK DRIVING IT
CERTAINLY GETS MY ATTENTION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT PEOPLE AND
NO MY NARRATIVE OF OUR THREE
YEAR OLD SON WHO WAS KILLED BY
HIT AND RUN MOTORIST AND- WHEN I
WAS ON A CARSON CITY COUNCIL
THIS WAS ABSOLUTELY AN ISSUE IN
THE CITY IN TERMS OF DRAG RACING
AND WE PUT SOME TOUGH ORDINANCES
IN PLACE. I DON'T THINK WE CAN
DO ENOUGH IN THIS SPACE IN ORDER
TO SAFEGUARD LIVES AND I AS ONE
OF THE YOUNG THE SPEAKERS ARE
SPEAKING IT REMINDED ME AND- OF
A SITUATION THAT TOOK PLACE IN
ONE OF MY CITIES COUPLE WEEKS
MONTHS AGO RATHER WHERE A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD WAS OUT WHEN HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN. ARM AND
VIEWING A STREET RACE- AND THEN
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THAT-
SOMEONE ALWAYS BRINGS A GUN. AND
SO THIS SIXTEEN YEAR OLD WAS
KILLED- IN MY DISTRICT AS A
RESULT OF BEING. PULLED INTO THE
STREET RACING VIEWING AND SEEN-
AND IT'S ALWAYS EVIDENCE OF THAT
SOMEONE ALWAYS BRINGS A GUN. AND
SO IT BREEDS THIS KINDS OF
SITUATIONS UNFORTUNATELY- BUT WE
HAVE TO PUT POLICIES IN PLACE-
SO THAT WE STRENGTHENED THE LAW
AND ALSO SAVE LIVES AT THE SAME
TIME AND SO. I MEAN THROUGH THE
ASPIC LEAVE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THIS BILL- ON THE FLOOR OF THE
STATE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING
THIS BEFORE THIS BODY. I THINK
IT WAS GIPSON AND I JUST WANNA
SAY AS- AS A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ALLEN I THINK IT'S A MEMBER
GALA. AS A MEMBER GABRIEL FOR
THIS MEASURE IRATE THIS SATURDAY
WENT ON A RIDE ALONG WITH THE
CATHOLIC HIGH PATROL IN THE BASE
OF POLICE DEPARTMENT- AS THEY
WERE ENGAGING IN ENHANCE- SHE
RACING SIDE SHOW ENFORCEMENT
THIS WEEKEND- AND I SAW FIRST
HAND- THE SIZE SHOWS THAT WERE
FORMING. A IN PARKING LOTS IN MY
COMMUNITY IN BAKERSFIELD- THAT
EVENTUALLY LED TO- OTHER SHE
RACES. HOUSE CITATIONS WERE-
THAT WERE MADE BUT A NUMBER OF-
DO YOU EYES WERE CAUGHT- IN
THIS- AND IS IT- AND FORSMAN
ACTION SO EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
TO KEEP OUR ROADS SAFE AND SO I
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP I WILL
OFFER YOU THE OPTION TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR- CO
AUTHORSHIP- AND FOR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS WANT TO THANK. OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AS WELL I KNOW HOW
PERSONAL THESE ISSUES ARE TOO I
KNOW WHAT A LEADER YOU HAVE BEEN
ON THEM- AND I THINK YOU SPOKE
REALLY TO THE MAIN PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL. WHICH IS TO SAVE
LIVES AND WE KNOW THAT THESE
INCIDENTS. ARE OCCURRING IN
COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE- THOSE COMMUNITIES MAY BE
DIFFERENT BUT THESE INCIDENTS
USUALLY ON THE SAME WAY. WE HAVE
HAD THE SAME THING A NUMBER OF
TRAGIC INCIDENTS IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY MY COMMUNITY
THAT HAVE ENDED IN THE DEATH OF
YOUNG PEOPLE. RIGHT SOMETIMES
ARE IN THE CAR SOMETIMES ARE NOT
IN THE CAR SOMETIMES THEY DIE
DURING THE SPEECH CONTEST IN
QUESTION SOMETIMES THEY DIE WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO. LEAVE THE
PROMISE US- BUT THE PART OF THE
POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO SAVE
LIVES AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE.
VICTIMS GROUP SUPPORTING IT
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE TRIPLE A
SUPPORTING IT THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
A LOT. OF LAW ENFORCEMENT BEHIND
IT- BUT IF I MIGHT MISTER TRY
JUST TO WANT TO RESPOND. TO THE
TO THE MILDOPPOSITION FROM THE
ACLU- WHO I WHO I OFTEN SEE EYE
TO EYE WITH. YOU KNOW THEIR
ARGUMENT AS YOU HEARD BASICALLY
BOILS DOWN TO- THIS IS NOT AS
DANGEROUS IN A PARKING LOT AS IT
IS ON A FREEWAY- AND I GUESS I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY SAY TO THAT-
THERE'S NO DATA. THERE'S NO
RESEARCH THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
THAT THEY SITE FOR THAT
PROPOSITION. I THINK COMMON TYPE
SENSE TELLS ME THE OPPOSITE.
THERE ARE PEDESTRIANS ON
FREEWAYS- BUT THEY'RE OFTEN
PEDESTRIANS AND PARKING LOTS
THIS IS WHERE PEOPLE GO TO
SKATEBOARD. THIS WORKABLE GO TO
TEACH THEIR KIDS TO RIDE A BIKE
SO. IN MY MIND THE DANGER IS
ACTUALLY INCREASE THE CHANCES
THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE AN
INNOCENT LIFE YOU LOST. IS
ACTUALLY INCREASED IN A FEW
MONTHS SO. AS THEY TALKED ABOUT
IT- YOU KNOW THEY UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR THE POLICY MORE
BROADLY. THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
WOULD ALIGN THE LAW- I THINK
CLARITY CONSISTENCY IN THE LAW
IS ALWAYS A GOOD THING IT'S ON
BEHALF OF THOSE. WHO HAVE BEEN-
YOU KNOW VICTIMS AND WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES IN SPEECH
CONTESTS THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON THIS BILL. I
THANK YOU VERY. WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND. MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY I
DAVIS. GIPSON HI GIPSON I KALRA
. LEE MEDINA INA I NAZARIAN WHEN
. O'DONNELL WARD WICKS WICKS I.
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THE BILL
ITSELF WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT UP IS
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN BY MR
HOLDEN. HE'S COMING UP I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US SO CLOSELY ON
THIS BILL. SHE IT. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY FOR PROCEED. MADAM
CHAIR YOU TOOK THE WORDS RIGHT
OUT OF MY MOUTH- I WANTED TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US AND
WITH THE BILL. AND I ASKED HER
ABOUT. I WILL ASK I WILL ADD A
FEW MORE ACOSTA THIS BUT I DO
APPRECIATE- THE DILIGENCE
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE
IMPORTANCE OF EXPANDING A
PROGRAM PROVIDING FREE TRANSIT
PASSES TO YOUNG PEOPLE AND- AND
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP.
TODAY AS I PRESENT AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN THE BILL THAT SEEKS TO
HAVE TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS OUR
STATE PROVIDE FARE FREE TRANSIT
PASSES TO USE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OR YOUNGER THIS BILL WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST NATION TO
COMPREHENSIVELY PROVIDE ACCESS
TO TRANSIT TO ITS USE. AND IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD DO SO AT THIS
HISTORIC MOMENT IN TIME WHEN
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP IS PROVING
INTEGRAL TO RESPONDING TO THE
FARE BOX REVENUE LOSSES OF THE
PANDEMIC ONGOING CLIMB INVOLVED
VOLATILITY AND RISING SOCIAL
INJUSTICE. MEMBERS I AM
CERTAINLY A CERTAIN MANY OF YOU
WILL RECALL YOUR YOUTH A WIN AS
A STRUGGLING STUDENT OR YOUNG
PERSON YOU HAD TO FRUGALLY
SCRAPE TOGETHER THE FUNDS TO
AFFORD GAS FOR YOUR CAR OR FARES
FOR BUS. AND NO DOUBT YOU'RE ALL
EMPATHETIC TO THE STRUGGLES OF
YOUNG CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM THE SAME STRESSES
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE FOR THOSE
MILLIONS OF YOUNG CALIFORNIANS
LOSE ACCESS TO TRANSIT IS
INSEPARABLE FROM THEIR CAPACITY
TO PURSUE THEIR EDUCATION.
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND UNTAMED THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN WOULD CREATE THE USE
TRANSIT PASS PILOT PROGRAM
STATEWIDE IN WOULD BE A
FRAMEWORK FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES
SO THAT THEY MAY PROVIDE. FARE
FREE BUS AND RAIL SERVICES TO
ALL USE TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER.
THIS INCLUSION OF ALL YOU TWENTY
FIVE AND UNDER WILL IT CAPS A
LATE THE LOWEST INCOME EARNING
PORTION OF OUR STATE'S
POPULATION PROVIDE THEM WITH
GENUINE INCENTIVES. TO USE
TRANSIT AND CONTINUE TO USE IT
BEYOND THE PROGRAM THEREBY
INCREASING RIDERSHIP IN
RIDERSHIP HABITS FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME. ADDITIONALLY AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD
REIMBURSE TRANSIT AGENCIES FOR
THEIR COSTS OF IMPLEMENTING AND
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM SO AS
TO MAKE THESE. PANDEMIC AFFECTED
AFFLICTED AND STRUGGLING TRANSIT
PROVIDERS HOLE AGAIN. RATHER
THAN HAVING TO FRONT THE COSTS
OF PROVIDING TRANSIT EQUITY FOR
OUR YOUTH TRANSIT AGENCIES CAN
REST ASSURED THAT THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM IN
THEIR MISSION TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS. TO ALL
THEY SERVE. AND IMPORTANTLY AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD ALSO
HOLD IN PLACE FOR THE DURATION
OF THE PROGRAM CURRENT SERVICE
AND EXPANSION PLANS TO ENSURE
THAT THE SERVICES ARE NOT CUT.
OR DRAWN DOWN FOR YOUTH. WHO
NEED THESE VITAL TRANSIT
ALLIANCE. CLOSING MY OFFICE HAS
MET WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS WILL
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND I'VE
WORKED TO DEVELOP SMART POLICY
WHICH UP WITH BOTH OUR YOUTH AND
THE TRANSIT SECTOR AND I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT I'M COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING AND ELIMINATING ANY
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
TRANSIT AGENCIES AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. WITH ME TODAY ON
THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETEEN NINETEEN AS YOU
LIKE LIPMAN THE DIRECTOR OF
DEVELOPMENT AND PROGRAMMING WITH
MOVE LA ONE OF LA'S PREMIER
TRANSIT ADVOCACY GROUPS. THAT
HAS BEEN WORKING TOWARDS TRANSIT
EQUITY SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN.
ANALYSTS AT JONES AN ORGANIZER
WITH YOUTH FOR CLIMATE JUSTICE
BASED OUT OF SANTA CRUZ AND A
CURRENT STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
CRUZ WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU- I'M ASSUMING
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE PHONE SO
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE- OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND WE WILL
LIMIT. TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES
APIECE WILL BE STRICT ABOUT THIS
FROM NOW ON FOR THE REST OF THE
HEARING THANK YOU. THEIR LIVES
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU FRIEDMAN CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
. THANK YOU CHAIR FRIEDMAN THIS
IS ELI THAT MEANT WE HAD TO MOVE
LA AND HONORABLE MEMBERS THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE ARE YOU
NAY NATION BUILT A BRAND BY MID
BUSINESS COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
MEASURE R. AND L. A. COUNTY THAT
IS FUNDING A HUNDRED TWENTY
BILLION. IN TRANSFORMATIVE
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
CREATING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF JOBS WE ALSO WORKED WITH THE
SETTLEMENT HOLD IN THE OFFICE
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW TO MOVE
FORWARD YOU TRANSIT PASS
LEGISLATION. INCLUDING AB
SEVENTEEN. SO WE'RE HERE TO
TESTIFY TO THAT THE- AND
PARTICULAR YOUR COMING MONTHLY
EVERY BIBLE THAT BEGAN TO. RIDER
MAXIMIZE VEHICLE TRIP. AND
LEGITIMATED ARE LARGE SCALE
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
FROM HIGH SPEED RAIL TO LOCAL
TRANSIT SYSTEMS. TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE EQUITY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETEEN WILL DO JUST
THAT WHILE ALSO CREATING A NEW
GENERATION OF TRANSIT USERS. AND
HELP UNDERSERVED YOUTH GET TO
CLASS ON TIME THANK YOU FOR
BEING AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
GO TO WORK FOR A DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT ENJOY ALL THE
CALIFORNIA HOT. DOCTOR FROM
CULTURE TO NATURE. TWENTY AFTER
THIRTY HAS SHOWN THE KIND
PROGRAM THEY THE NINETY NINE
WILL CREATE IT. SIX WAY TO
ACCESS TO FREE TRANSPORTATION
FOR YOU AND HELP REDUCE CURRENT
TRANSPORTATION INEQUITY. LETTING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS IN FACT
HE SAID THE U. AUTHORIZED IN
TWENTY TWENTY FROM UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES. WHICH
WAS DONE WITH THE SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
CONFIRMED THAT THE PROGRAMS LKE
THE ONE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
NINETEEN CREATE WOULD BE GOOD
FOR BOTH RIDERS AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES I QUOTE. THE REPORT
FOUND THAT HE CHEATED THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL YOU CONTRAVENTION BE
INTEGRATED AND COMPREHENSIVE
POLICIES TO CHEAT CALIFORNIA'S
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
DO TODAY HE'S PROGRAMS ALSO HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO HELP LOW INCOME
RIDERS ESCAPE POVERTY. AND
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE LAST ABSENT
OR TARDY SCHOOL AND INCREASE
SAFETY AND REDUCE THEIR INVASION
TICKET. WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY
TARGET YOUTH OF COLOR. ALL GOOD
REASONS TO SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETEEN BUT THE MOST
COMPELLING. THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE. AND. QUICKEST WAY TO
INCREASE TRANSIT RIDERSHIP. AS
WE RECOVER FROM A GOAL TENDER.
WE THOUGHT TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
DROPPED HER. AND INAGA COVERED.
AND IT GOT PRICES. ITS PROGRAM
WILL BRING BACK PRICE AND REDUCE
TRAVEL WITHIN MONTHS OF BEING
FUNDED IN MARCH YOU'RE SEEING A
TREND ALREADY IN L. A. COUNTY
WHERE PILOTS TRANSIT PASS
PROGRAM FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE.
ENGINEER BECAUSE YOU WATCH IN
OCTOBER AND NOW AVAILABLE TO ONE
POINT THREE MILLION L. A. COUNTY
STUDENTS AT THE OVER ONE MILLION
TRIPS IN LESS THAN SIX MARK.
HUGHES RIDERSHIP IS DRIVING OUT
THE METRO'S RIDERSHIP RECOVERY
WHICH IS LEADING THE STATE. SO
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT OUR
CLIENT IN BMC GOLD THE COURT.
SUPPORTED FUNDING A PROGRAM IS
NOT ONLY EFFECTIVE POLICY BUT IN
THE SENSE OF THE FUTURE OF THIS
STATE WE WERE QUITE HIGH. ABOUT
THANK YOU- CHAIR. OKAY NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LESLIE JONES I'M TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD AND I'M AN ORGANIZER
VIEWS THE CLIMATE JUSTICE
INCREASE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION AND ISSUE NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART I THINK UC
SANTA CRUZ WHICH IS THE FIRST
PLACE WHERE I LEARNED NOT
NAVIGATE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AFTER GROWING UP IN CAR BASED
LOS ANGELES. TAKING THE BOXES
THE FIRST TRUE FREEDOM I
EXPERIENCE IN A NEW REPORT THIS
FREEDOM IS EXTENDED TO ALL THE
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS WHO CAN
DRIVE THEM AROUND CONTROL THAT
WOULD EXPAND TRANSIT ACCESS I
HAVE A TRANSPORTATION FEE
INCLUDED IN MY COLLECTION WHICH
GETS ME FREE AND UNLIMITED
ACCESS TO ALL SANTA CRUZ METRO
BUSES HOWEVER MOST STUDENTS
DON'T GET THAT. PLUS FIFTY IS
EXPENSIVE AND BURDENSOME AND IT
DOESN'T COVER ACCESS TO FARTHER
DESTINATIONS LIKE NEARBY SAN
JOSE BEFORE I LEARNED THAT THIS
HEARING WITH OVER THE PHONE I
WOULD DEEPLY STRESSED OUT ABOUT
HOW I WOULD GET TO SACRAMENTO
FROM SANTA CRUZ IT WOULD HAVE
COST ME A HUNDRED AND THREE
DOLLARS TO GET HERE OVER A
QUARTER OF MY MONTHLY INCOME.
ACOSTA TRANSIT IS STRAINING AND
WORRISOME FOR MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
TRANSITIVE INEFFECTIVELY FOR
STUDENTS TO GET SCHOOL WORK AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO MAKE THE CHOICE BETWEEN
TRANSIT FARE IMPORTANT LIFE
DECISIONS LIKE PURCHASING
TEXTBOOKS NECESSARY FOR SCHOOL
OR THE CHOICE TO BUY HEALTHY
GROCERIES SUCH AS FAST FOOD AND
YET OVER TEN MILLION STUDENTS IN
USING CALIFORNIA MAKE THE
DECISION DAILY. TREND NOT JUST A
SERVICE IT'S A LIFELINE FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
WILLING TO ENABLE YOU ACCESS IT
MATTER OF FACTLY MUST UPLOAD FOR
YOU AS WELL AS OUR TRANSIT
PROVIDERS WHO ARE SPECIALLY IN
NEED NOW AT THE COVE IN NINETEEN
CRISIS HAS BADLY AFFECTED THE
TRANSIT SYSTEM THIS BILL WILL
HELP PROVIDE AN EXPANDED GOING
FORWARD FAIR FOR YOU TRANSIT
ALSO HAS REAL CLIMATE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL IMPACTS
EIGHTY NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD
DECREASE SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM CAN
EXTENSIVE EXTRA CURRICULAR
OPPORTUNITIES. POSITIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD INTERVENTION FOR
CLIMATE EMERGENCY AND. HE'S
PASSAGE WILL CREATE LONG TERM
MMHM PAYING PA TRANS RIDERS.
SHOULD LIKE ME. PLEASE JOIN TEAM
. AND USE CLIMATE JUSTICE AN
IMPROVING TREND ACCESS AN ECHO
FOR POWER. YOU BY PASSING EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETEEN. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
OKAY YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
MUCH. OF DO WE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WERE TO SPEAK AT OUR- WE
HAVE TO WE- AN OP. LET'S GO TO
THE L. IT ISN'T. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ALEX CLIFFORD. AND MICHAEL-
IT PIMENTEL IF MICHAEL'S HERE HE
CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE WITNESS ON THE
PHONE. THE BE SURE YOU PUSH THE
BUTTON AND MY BUTTON. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXACTED RECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY
EIGHTY FIVE TRAINS AND RELIGION
SEE MEMBERS TO VOICE OUR-
REGRETTABLE OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN AS AMENDED ON
MARCH SEVENTH. I AS I BEGIN MY
REMARKS I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT AS AN ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THE ELECTIVE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THERAPY
PROGRAMS BY CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCIES. LIKE THE AUTHOR REVIEW
THESE PROGRAMS AS A KEY
MECHANISM FOR EXPANDING ACCESS
TRANSIT SERVICE WELCOMING
WRITERS BACK TO OUR SYSTEMS IN
BUILDING LIFELONG TRANSIT RIDERS
IN FACT WE ARE CO SPONSORING SB
NINE FORTY TWO THIS YEAR TO
ALLOW AGENCIES TO USE OUR
FORMULA. OF THE TOP FUNDS TO
SUSTAIN FARE FREE PROGRAMS
BEYOND THE PILOT PHASE. WE ALSO
WORKED WITH THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR TO SECURE LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET TO REMOVE A LONG STANDING
STATUTORY BARRIER. TO THE STAFF
WHICH MEANT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
NOW AS AN INDUSTRY WE HAVE MADE
PROGRESS IN DELIVERING FOR FREE
PROGRAMS ALBEIT. WITH DISTINCT
LOCALLY DICTATED PARAMETERS
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
EXTERNAL FUNDING SUCH PROGRAMS
REQUIRE. SEVERAL OF OUR LARGEST
AGENCIES IN LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO SAN DIEGO ORANGE
COUNTY RIVERSIDE AND SACRAMENTO.
ALL OVERSEE FOR FREE PROGRAMS
FOR INDIVIDUALS AGE EIGHTEEN AND
UNDER. IN OUR OPPOSITION AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN IS PREDICATED%
ON THREE MAIN FACTORS THAT WE
BELIEVE MUST BE SCRUTINIZED BY
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE BROADER
LEGISLATURE. ONE THE BILL
REQUIRES TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
ESTABLISH FAIR FREE PROGRAMS ARE
LOSE ACCESS TO STATE TRANSIT
FUNDS. TOTALING APPROXIMATELY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
TO THE BILL LACKS FUNDING OFFSET
FARE REVENUES THOUGH IT DOES
ALLUDE TO POTENTIAL FOR SUCH
FUNDING AND CURRENTLY FILLS TO
CONTEMPLATE THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO ADDRESS
WHAT WILL BE INDUCED DEMAND FOR
TRANSIT SERVICES AS WELL AS OP
STORE COST. FINALLY THE BILL'S
PROPOSED STRUCTURE FOR
REIMBURSING TRANSIT AGENCIES
WHICH CURRENTLY IS NOT IN PRINT.
WOULD RELY ON EXHAUSTIVE
DOCUMENTATION OF TRIPS PROVIDED
INDIVIDUALS AGE TWENTY FIVE AND
UNDER AND WOULD LIKELY REQUIRE
THE PURCHASE OF NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THOUSANDS OF
TRANSIT VEHICLES. IN THE
ESTABLISH OF NEW OPERATIONS
PROTOCOLS. AND SO WERE UNABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TODAY WE
DO KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR IS
PREPARING NEW AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE WORK IS
DOING TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PUBLIC
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
LET'S MOVE TO THE WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE. OP IF YOU COULD
PLEASE FIND ALEX CLIFFORD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CEO OF THE SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT AND VICE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR COORDINATED TRANSPORTATION
NOTICE CAL ACT IN A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF KELEX TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN. WELL IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AMENDMENTS
ARE BEING DRAFTED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
IMPRESSED. CAL ACT IS A
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION WITH OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY MEMBERS
COMPRISED MAINLY OF SMALL URBAN
RURAL TRANSIT AND PARATRANSIT
OPERATORS WHAT WE DO NOT OPPOSE
CREATING TRANSIT PASS PROGRAMS
BUT IT ALL HINGES ON SUFFICIENT
AND STABLE FUNDING AND LOCAL
CONTROL. TRANSIT OPERATORS
ACROSS THE STREET STATE HAVE
TAKEN PROACTIVE MEASURES TO
PARTNER WITH SCHOOLS
UNIVERSITIES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
TRANSIT PASSES AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN WOULD UNDERMINE THESE
AGREEMENTS. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A MANDATE TO PROVIDE FREE
TRANSIT ANYONE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AND UNDER IN ORDER TO REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR EXISTING STATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS. THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT SUFFICIENT STATE
FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS TO COVER THE COST
OF IMPLEMENTING ADMINISTERING
AND BACKFILLING THE LOSS FARE
REVENUE NOT TO MENTION THE
FISCAL DEMANDS PLACED ON
CALTRANS TO ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES THIS BILL WILL IMPOSE
ON SMALL TO MID SIZE TRANSIT
AGENCIES. EVEN IF PROTECTIONS
ARE ADDED TO THE BILL OF THE
MANDATE CONDITIONAL ON
SUFFICIENT FUNDING THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDES NO INCENTIVE. FOR
SCHOOLS UNIVERSITIES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS TO CONTINUE THEIR
TRANSIT PASS PROGRAMS WHEN AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN PROVIDES THEM
THE SAME SERVICE FOR FREE. WITH
THE CURRENT UNFUNDED MANDATE TO
PROVIDE PARA TRANSIT SERVICES
TRANSIT OPERATORS HAVE SEEN MANY
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES SHIFTING
TRANSPORTING THEIR CLIENTS FROM
PRIVATE SERVICE. TO PARA TRANSIT
SERVICE. BERMAN IS GROWN IN
RECENT YEARS WAS REGIONAL
CENTERS FOR GOING THERE DIRECTLY
OPERATED IN CONTRACTED SERVICES.
IN FAVOR PLACING THE
TRANSPORTATION COST OF THEIR
CLIENT ON PUBLIC PARATRANSIT
SERVICE. AND EACH TO ME I'M
GONNA NEED YOU TO- FINISH UP
HERE. I WILL DO THAT IN ADDITION
FEDERAL AND- ADA AND TITLE SIX
REQUIRE THAT WE PROVIDE A
COMPLEMENTARY PARATRANSIT- THREE
IF THIS BILL WERE TO GO THROUGH-
YOU SHOULD NOT PLACE ANYTHING
ANYTHING FREE TRANSFEREE MUCH.
THANK YOU OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM
SO IF THERE'S ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
OF AB. NINETEEN NINETEEN PLEASE
COME UP TO THE MIKE OKAY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
MY NAME IS DAN OPEN PLUS I'M
ACTUALLY HERE AS THE FATHER OF
TWO CHILDREN OF THE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THEY HAVE YOUTH SAY JUSTICE NAME
AND YEAH WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND
IT'S A GREAT IDEA THANK YOU
THANK YOU PERFECT. OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM SO
CAN WE PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. WE GO TO LINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN THE
PARK THANK. NEXT WE MOVE ON TO
LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DO YOU HAVE YOUR PHONE
MUTED. WILL MOVE ON THE LINE
SIXTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE HARD
WORK YES. WE HAVE BEEN AND- THIS
IS MARK BROOKS RICH CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MR TRAWL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF NEW TREND THE PAST
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MARIN WITH CITIZENS CLIMATE
LOBBY SANTA CRUZ CHAPTER IN
THROUGH THE ETHICALLY SUPPORT AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN. NEXT IS LINE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREEN MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
STANDING AROUND HOPE POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR CLIMATE PARENTS
SPEAKING STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JANICE DOWNEY EISEMAN OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA GREEN
NEW DEAL COALITION AND SUPPORT.
MEXICO TO LINE SIXTY FOUR GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS VICTORIA
ROLLED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE GO TO LINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TURNING HER COMPUTER ON BEHALF
BECAUSE THAT WATER. NEEDS
TRANSACTION ADDITION. MEXICO
LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THERE THIS IS AMY THOMPSON
WITH TRANSFORM INTO PORT THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE GO TO LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD ALSO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GARY YES
GO AHEAD INTERLUDES NORTH
WESTWOOD NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OTHER COMMENTS YOU
MAKE AND YOU MAY I GO AHEAD
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO TO
COMMITTEEI WANTED TO ASK THE
AUTHOR IF HE'S ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. YES OKAY
THANK YOU SO LET'S TAKE IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE THIS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MANY BODY
. TO DALY JUST ONE COMMENTED IT
SEEMS TO ME AND MAYBE YOU'RE
WORKING ON THIS WITH YOUR
AMENDMENTS MR HOLDEN BUT TO. THE
TIME FRAME IS A LITTLE BIT TO.
AMBITIOUS IN TERMS OF.
DETERMINING HOW SUCCESSFUL.
PROGRAM WILL BE. SO EITHER SOME
REPORTS MIDSTREAM. OR A SHORTER
PERIOD MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT'S
WORTHWHILE. NOT NECESSARILY A
SUNSET THOSE TRICKS SUNSET BUT
JUST MORE. INFORMATION SURE YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT I THINK THAT
CERTAINLY IS A VALID POINT I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN AND EVEN
THE COMMITTEE'S REPORT WHERE
THERE HAVE BEEN STUDIES WHETHER
THERE AND UNIVERSITIES IN TEXAS
OR OF WHERE THE PROGRAM SERVES
BEEN TESTED AFTER THE PANDEMIC
WHERE THEY SEE RIDERSHIP UP. OF
THAT. OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
MOVING AWAY FROM THE AUTOMOBILE
WHICH THOSE ARE TWO VERY
IMPORTANT GOALS SO I THINK THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT EVEN FROM THIS
REPORT ON THE DOLI THAT THIS IS
THE KIND OF PROGRAM THAT IS
GOING TO CREATE A NEW GENERATION
OF PUBLIC TRANSIT RIDERS- CLEAN
AIR OUT OF THE AUTOMOBILES AND
CREATING SOMETHING EFFICIENT AND
COST EFFECTIVE FOR THEM TO MOVE
AROUND BUT BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
SUGGESTS I THINK. YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOT PROBABLY ONE BILL
THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE SOME KIND
OF CHECK AND SEE HOW WELL IT'S
WORKING INUNDATED MEET ITS
INTENDED GOAL SO I. RECEIVE YOUR
COMMENTS I FEEL IT'S A VERY VERY
WORTHWHILE BILL JUST TO. AND
WANTED YOU TO HEAR THAT COMMENT
IN TERMS OF- GATHERING DATA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD THANK
MANAGER I'M NOT SURE IF THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION HAPPY TO MAKE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL OR
OTHERWISE SECOND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- OBVIOUSLY
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE
FOR YOUTH- AND OUR YOUNG ADULTS
TO. BE ABLE TO GET AROUND US
JUST ONE LESS- BURDEN ON ON A
VERY- EXPENSIVE- WAY OF LIFE
THAT WE HAVE MANY OF OUR CITIES
AND THAT WE'VE SEEN THIS OPERATE
VERY WELL- AND AS A CONCEPT AS
SOMETHING MOVE PUSHING FOR
LOCALLY- I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE OPPOSITION'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL THAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ONE TALK ABOUT. LOST
REVENUE AND THAT IS- IF- YOU
FIRST OF ALL I RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU KNOW THE PROVISION OF THIS
WILL PROBABLY WORK REALLY
CLOSELY AND APPROPRIATIONS AND
OTHER SPACES- TO REALLY TRY TO
FIND THE- STATE- C. OBLIGATION-
THAT THAT SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
SUPPORT ALL THIS OF COURSE ALL
THAT WILL FLOW THROUGH TO OUR
TRANSIT AGENCIES. TO TRY TO
MAKE- YOU HOLE FOR THAT BUT IF
THIS INDUCES ADDITIONAL
RIDERSHIP. WRITERS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BE ON THAT.
SYSTEM AN OTHERWISE NOT PAYING A
FARE. BUT WE HAVE EMPTY SEATS
THAT ARE DRIVING AROUND THE
DISTRICT HOW IS IT FROM I GUESS
A MARGINAL. COST PERSPECTIVE
THAT THAT YOU WOULD WE COUNT
THAT AS REDUCED REVENUE. SO
LITTLE REDUCED REVENUES REVENUE
THAT'S LOSS OF THE FIREBOX. AND
SO IN THE STATE WE COLLECT ABOUT
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. IN REVENUES FROM THE
FAREBOX NOW STIPULATE THAT THAT
DOES SPEAK TO THE POPULATION AS
A WHOLE. AT THE SPECIFIC
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT'S EXPECTED
WITHIN THIS BILL. INTO AGENCIES
WOULD IN THE NEAR TERM BECAUSE
THE BILL'S PROVISION THAT
STRUCTURE IS THAT AGENCIES AFTER
FOREGO. REVENUES AS A MEANS OF
SUPPORTING THEIR SYSTEMS. LOSE
OUT DIRECTLY ON THOSE
INVESTMENTS. BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT THE AREA WHERE WE'VE BEEN
CONCERNED AND THAT SPOKEN TO
WITHIN OUR LETTER. IS THAT
CONCEPT OF INDUCED DEMAND. NOW
GRANTED ARE AT TIMES INSTANCES
OF VEHICLES THAT ARE RUNNING
EMPTY OR RUNNING WITH LESS THAN
FULL CAPACITY. IN THOSE CASES
YOU HAVE CAPACITY THAT CAN BE
FILLED. BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS INDUCED DEMAND IN NEW
AREAS AND THERE ARE GOING TO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL SERVICE. THAT
MEANS NEW VEHICLES THAT MEANS
NEW OPERATORS ALL THAT COMES
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL COSTS OTHER
THAN BORN BY THE AGENCY. I KNOW
THAT IS FURTHER COMPOUNDED AS A
CONCERN WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE REALITY THAT RIGHT
NOW. EVERY AGENCY IN THE STATE
IS FACING AN OPERATOR SHORTAGE.
AND SO IF YOU'VE MADE A
COMMITMENT FOR AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE BUT THEY
CAN'T FILL THAT COMMITMENT THAT
ALSO DOES CREATE SOME CHALLENGES
FROM AN OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE.
OR BY AGENCIES MAY HAVE TO BE
PASSING UP CUSTOMERS BECAUSE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THE
FINANCIAL OR HUMAN RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE. AND SO IT'S ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM THAT WE HAVE CONCERNED.
ON THAT OF COURSE WE ARE.
INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO EXPLORE FURTHER HOW
THIS CAN BE ADDRESSED- BUT
THAT'S CHIEFLY WHERE CONCERNS
LIE OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT IT IS
MY HOPE THAT YOU KNOW IF WE ARE
ESPECIALLY A YOUNGER AGE- REALLY
ENCOURAGING. INDIVIDUALS USE
TRANSIT. THROUGH A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS WHERE WE ARE FUNDING THAT-
WITH ANY ANY INDUCED DEMAND THAT
IS THERE- WOULD OPTIMIZE A
SYSTEM THAT'S ALREADY RUNNING- I
THINK IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS TO
SEE. WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE
EXCEEDED CAPACITY AND WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT ADDITIONAL
OPERATIONAL BUT. I DON'T FEEL
LIKE WHERE THEY'RE CLOSE TO
THEIR AT- WE ALREADY SAID- RIGHT
FOR. A LOT OF OUR- AND THE
SYSTEMS AS IT IS I SEE THIS IS.
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BETTER UTILIZATION. OF
THAT SYSTEM AND HOPEFULLY
REALLY- SPUR. INTEREST BY THAT
GENERATION FOR THE REST OF THEIR
ADULTHOOD AS WELL SO THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL HAPPY TO MOVE IT
AND I KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
ANYONE ELSE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES MILITARY FIRST OF ALL
WHAT WE WERE SORT OF A EXCITED
AT THE BEGINNING WHEN WE STARTED
THIS MEETING BY ENTHUSIASTICALLY
JOINED IN WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND ITS RECOMMENDATION ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND THAT ESSENTIALLY
WHAT I'VE HEARD IN THE
PRESENTATION FOR THE OPPOSITION.
WAS NOT RECOGNIZING APPRECIATING
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT. MANDATING
OR OR- PENALIZING A BASED ON THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE CHAIR AND
STAFF- ANY PROVIDER OR AGENCY
THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY APPROVED-
OF PROVIDING A TRANSIT PROGRAM
THAT THEY NOW MUST CHOOSE
BETWEEN HOW THEY ALLOCATE THOSE
RESOURCES SO I THINK WE
ADDRESSED. ALREADY THAT CONCERN
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
TO NOTE THAT THERE WAS ALSO
REFERENCING AND THE- AMENDMENTS
AROUND AND M. O. USE OF THOSE I
THINK IT WAS MENTIONED BY THE-
THE OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
THAT WHY WOULD YOU GIVE THE
MONEY TO. ME WHY NO ONE WOULD
WANT TO PARTICIPATE OR OR PUT
THEIR OWN RESOURCES AND IF THE
STATE IS GOING TO GIVE THE MONEY
WELL THAT'S WITH THEM OR YOU IS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS. THAT IF YOU
ARE CURRENTLY FOUND RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT A STUDENT TRANSIT. PASS
PROGRAM LIKE THIS THE ANY
ADDITIONAL MONIES FROM THE STATE
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE TO
AUGMENT NOT SUPPLANT. AND THAT'S
WHAT MY UNDERSTANDING AND SO TO
THAT END I THINK THAT THE
QUESTIONS AT LEAST THAT WERE
PRESENTED I'M ALWAYS. CONTINUING
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND FIND
OTHER ELEMENTS THAT MIGHT BE A
CONCERN THAT ARE THE REAL- BUT I
THINK THE REAL SUBSTANTIVE ONCE
A- BY VIRTUE THE COMMITTEE HAS.
AND ARE ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS HAS BEEN ADDRESSED- I
MEAN I AGAIN IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING WHETHER YOU REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY. WITH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. ARE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS- MY- SAN DIEGO
SAN DIEGO STATE. FRESNO YOU KNOW
DOMINGUEZ HILLS THERE'S THESE
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING
FOR SOLUTIONS TODAY. THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR AN ANSWER TO THE
ECONOMIC BURDENS THAT BAY
PERSINGER FEELING AND THEREFORE
AND AS AN EXTENSION THE PARENTS
ARE FEELING. AND SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY WITHOUT GOING ANYONE
TALKSTO MOVE I THINK A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM FORWARD WHERE
THE STATE AND WE HAVE A HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR. BUDGET
S. THAT'S THAT'S ATTACHED TO
THIS SO. I THINK WE THOUGHT WITH
THE COMMITTEES ASSISTANCE AROUND
THE CORNER AROUND ISSUES THAT.
HAVE BEEN ARTICULATED AS
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS AND TRY TO I
TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT. THANK YOU AND YOUR
PASSION FOR THIS IS CERTAINLY
CLEAR AND YOU- COMMITTEE
COMPLETELY AGREES WITH YOU. ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF TRYING TO
CREATE WRITERS AND DEVELOPING
THE NEXT GENERATION OF WRITERS
AND OUR STUDENTS ARE ARE OFTEN
TRANSIT DEPENDENT AND THIS WOULD
BE A HUGE BOON TO THEM AND I.
APPRECIATE YOUR HAVING WORKED
WITH US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T INADVERTENTLY- FINANCIALLY
IMPACT OF THE TRANSLATE AGENCIES
AND PUT THEM IN THE POSITION TO
TRY OF EITHER HAVING TO CUT
SERVICE FOR INSTANCE- OR- A FILL
THE MANDATES OF THE BILL. SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WATCHING AS IT MOVES THROUGH ITS
OTHER COMMITTEES. WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY I
DAVIS GIPSON. GIPSON I KALRA.
LEE MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN O'DONNELL. WARD WARD I
WICKS. SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU THE
BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN OKAY NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE BY
MR QUIRK YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY SIR. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. VERY GOOD.
WELL THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
- MOBILE FUELING THIS SERVICE
THAT RAPIDLY EMERGED THROUGH
START UPS IN RECENT YEARS AND AN
INDUSTRY THAT STATE AND LOCAL
REGULATIONS HAVE NOT CAUGHT UP
WITH YET. CURRENTLY MANY ARE
DISTRICTS REQUIRE VAPOR RECOVERY
SYSTEM WHICH ONLY APPLIES TO
CONVENTIONAL GAS STATIONS AND
THEREFORE PROHIBITS RETAIL
MOBILE FUELING. DOES THAT USE
BAKER RECOVERY TECHNOLOGY THAT
IS CERTIFIED BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. FURTHER WHILE
SOME MOBILE FEW ALERTS USED
SOUND VAPOR RECOVERY SYSTEMS
THERE MANY OTHERS THAT USE
STANDARD PICKUP TRUCK ST OPERATE
UNREGULATED DUE TO OUTDATED
DISTRICT RULES. AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE INITIATES UP TO DATE
LOCAL REGULATIONS THAT ACCOUNT
FOR THE UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS
OF THE MOBILE FUEL INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL WILL NOT ONLY ALLOW
COMPLIANT MOBILE FUEL ORDERS TO
OPERATE MORE SMOOTHLY ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS. WILL ALSO ENTER
IT WILLALSO ENSURE THAT
OPERATIONS ACROSS THE STATE MEET
THE HIGHEST ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. ALL IN THE ANALYSIS
IS CONCERNED STATED THAT THE
BILL WILL UNDER MY DISTRICT
REGULATION OF STATIONARY
SOURCES. I CERTAINLY THAT'S NOT
OUR INTENT TO KNOWLEDGE JUST THE
LANGUAGE IN THE NEXT POLICY
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
NOT THE CASE. THE REGION WHERE
DISTRICTS ARE CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL REGULATIONS.
PREVENT THIS I WILL AMEND THE
BILL. TO ALLOW AIR DISTRICTS
TIME TO EITHER ADOPT THEIR OWN
RULES. OR ADOPT A- FOR EXAMPLE
MOBILE FUELING FROM PERMITTING.
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH THE AIR
DISTRICTS TO SEE WHAT THE TIME
SCALE FOR THAT SHOULD BE- SO
THIS WOULD PREVENT THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL THE OTHER THING IS THIS
NOW IS ENTIRELY RUN BY THE LOCAL
DISTRICTS SO THEY HAVE FULL
REGULATION THEY HAVE FULL.
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE AND VERY
HAVE FULL KNOWLEDGE OF WHERE
PEOPLE WILL BE. ARE THAT ARE
DOING THE MOBILE FUELING. DOT
MOBILE FUELING CAN ALSO HELP THE
TRANSITION FROM FOSSIL FUELS BY
DISPENSING NEW NEW ALTERNATIVE
FUELS I AM THIRTY MINUTES AWAY.
FROM THE CLOSEST HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL STATION. OF IFSOMEBODY
WERE DELIVERING HIJINKS TO ME
I'D BE VERY HAPPY. IN ADDITION
WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE TRANSITION
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS WE NEED
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR THOSE IN
WHEELCHAIRS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
DIFFERENTLY ABLE TO ACCESS THE
FUEL THEY NEED. BY BRINGING FUEL
TO FLEETS THE NET AMOUNT OF FUEL
USED IN POLLUTION GENERATED
THROUGH VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
IS LIKELY REDUCE. AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE IS CO SPONSORED BY
BOOSTER FUELS THE UNITED SPINAL
ASSOCIATION AND HAS SUPPORT FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS ADVOCATES. AND
FIRE SAFETY GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE. WITH ME TODAY ARE JOE
OKAY PAKU FROM BOOSTER FUELS AND
DAN OKON FIRST REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO TO
YOUR WITNESSES. FEW MINUTES
PLEASE. THANK YOU DR QUIRK CHAIR
FRIEDMAN VICE CHAIR FONG AND ON
A REAL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JOSEPH A POCKET WHEN
I AM THE CHIEF POLICY OFFICER
FOR BREWSTER A MOBILE ENERGY
DELIVERY COMPANY AND A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL BEFORE YOU. I LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING CHAIR
FRIEDMAN FOR HEARING THE BILL
TODAY. MOBILE FRIEDMAN ITS-
MOBILE FEELING EXCUSE ME. IT'S A
NEW INDUSTRY THAT WAS BASED ON A
SIMPLE I AND I AM A I AM A
PREFERRED FOR. YEAH I'LL NEVER
LIVE THAT ONE DOWN. FOR THANK TO
MOBILE FUELING THE NEW INDUSTRY
THAT WAS BASED ON A SIMPLE IDEA
WHAT IF YOU'LL COULD BE
DELIVERED STRAIGHT TO THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT MOST LIKE THE SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES FOR WHOM
ACCESS TO GAS STATIONS. IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT. LOBAL
FEELING IS THE GREENEST WAY TO
DELIVER FUEL BECAUSE IT REDUCES
BILL AT SPILLAGE ARE YOU SICK
USING SPECIALLY TRAINED
EMPLOYEES WHO AVOID COMMON
FUELING MISTAKES. IT REDUCES
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
EMISSIONS BY BEING ABLE TO FEEL
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED VEHICLES
WITH JUST ONE TANKER. THEREBY
ELIMINATING HUNDREDS OF TRIPS TO
THE GAS STATION. AND IT REDUCES
RELIANCE ON UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANKS AT GAS STATIONS WHICH
OFTEN WE CAN TO OUR GROUND.
GLOBAL ENERGY DELIVERY IS ALSO
KEY TO ACCELERATING ADOPTION OF
ALTERNATIVE FUELS BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. LIKE
BRICK AND MORTAR STATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE LESS THAN 2% OF GAS
STATIONS CURRENTLY OFFER
RENEWABLE DIESEL. BUT BOOSTER
BEGAN OFFERING RENEWABLE DIESEL
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO AND
ALREADY WE HAVE CONVERTED 95% OF
OUR DIESEL CLIENTS TO RENEWABLE
DIESEL. THE SAME PROMISE EXISTS
WITH OTHER ALTERNATIVE FUELS
SUCH AS HYDROGEN AND EASY
CHARGING. UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
OUTDATED RULES MORE THAN HALF OF
THE THIRTY FIVE AIR DISTRICTS
AND CALIFORNIA BAR MOBILE
FEELING. THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE AIR DISTRICTS TO ENACT
RULES FOR MOBILE FEELING IN A
MANNER THAT ENSURE THE
PROTECTION OF THE ENVIRONMENT IN
THREE KEY WAYS. NUMBER ONE ONLY
CARPET CERTIFIED MOBILE FEELERS
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO OPERATE. TO
EACH DISTRICT WOULD BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH THEIR OWN THROUGHPUT
LIMITS SENSITIVE RECEPTORS
STANDARDS. AND OTHER MEASURES TO
ADDRESS DISTRICT SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS. AND
THREE AS DR QUICK MENTIONED THAT
THERE IS A SEGMENT OF THE MOBILE
FUELING INDUSTRY THAT HAS BEEN
DEEMED FIFTY TIMES WORSE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT ACCORDING TO THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGER
CAN I HAVE A FINISH UP BECAUSE
YOU'RE OVER THE TWO MINUTES.
WITH THAT WE HOPE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL APPROVE THE BILL
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NONE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DAN OPEN PLUS. PUBLIC
POLICY. MANAGER FOR THE C. F.
I'LL SEE THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS. I'M HERE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIVE SIX THREE. WHICH PROPOSES A
MORE CONSISTENT REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT FOR MOBILE FEELING.
AND PROVIDES A SAFE AND HEALTHY
ACCESS TO- FEELING. WE ARE
STATEWIDE DISABILITY RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS SERVICES THE
MEMBERSHIP. ASSOCIATION FOR ITS
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY FIVE.
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. I
WANT PRESS INDEPENDENT LIVING-
WE ARE PURPOSES SUPPORT PEOPLE
WITH ALL TYPES OF DISABILITIES.
IN MAINTAINING A BECOMING
INDEPENDENT WITH. TOO MANY
RESOURCES AND OUR ASSISTANCE OR
TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY MAY NEED.
AND WE SERVE OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS THE STATE. I SEE A FILE
C. IS ASO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SMART FEELING
THE COALITION WITH YOU TODAY
THAT IS URGING POLICY MAKERS TO
ALLOW MOBILE FEELING. BECAUSE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. MANY
OF US STILL NEED AN ALTERNATIVE
TO THE GAS STATION. FOR PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES ACCESS TO
CONVENTIONAL GAS STATION OFTEN
BROOMS PROVES EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE. GAS
STATIONS ARE NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND AS AN
EXAMPLE I AM A PERSON WITH A
DISABILITY I HAVE DWARFISM WHICH
IS A FORM OF SKELETAL DYSPLASIA
I AM SHORTER THAN AVERAGE ABOUT
FOUR FEET SIX INCHES TALL. AND
LITERALLY I LEVEL WITH AND THOSE
LEVEL WITH GAS PUMPS AND THE
NOZZLES AND I'M ALSO INHALING
THE FUMES AS A PRINT AS I- PUMP
UP. IT DOESN'T STOP THERE I ALSO
FIND IT DIFFICULT TO ACCESS THE
POINT OF SALE DEVICE TO. READ MY
CREDIT CARD. I'M SPEAKING FOR
THOUSANDS OF CALTRAIN DRYERS
DISABILITIES WHO CAN'T GET AN
ATTENDANT. THEY ALSO COME OUT OF
THE STATION OFFICER COMMAND
STORE THE COME OUT PUT MY GAS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE USUALLY THE ONLY
ONE TO TEN ON DUTY AND HERE SHE
CAN'T LEAVE THE CASHIER. LESS
AGO ACROSS THE BOARD ORGAN WHICH
HAS FULL SERVICE SO INTENT. THE
MOBILE FEELING ON THE MAN IS A
RAPIDLY GROWING SERVICE THAT
OFFERS PEOPLE DISABILITIES. A
HEALTHIER MORE CONVENIENT AND
ECONOMICAL ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE.
OPTIONS FOR FILLING UP. WE
ENCOURAGE YOU YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M- WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- BRENDAN TWICE.
LEAVING THE ROOM. THANK YOU.
AND YOU JUST NEED TO PUSH THE
BUTTON BEFORE YOU SPEAK I DID
THANK YOU I THINK OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
BRENDAN TELLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS FROM ALL THIRTY FIVE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING PUBLIC
HEALTH PROVIDING CLEAN AIR FOR
ALL OUR RESIDENTS WERE
RESPECTFULLY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE CAPCO
IS DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CANCER CAUSING. TOXIC EMISSIONS
AS WELL AS THE CRITERIA
POLLUTANT EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE OPERATIONS THAT'S WHY
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
TAKING A THOUGHTFUL AND MEASURED
APPROACH TO HOW THEY APPROACH
THE ISSUE OF ON DEMAND MOBILE
FEELING TAKING IN ACCOUNT
CONSIDERATION OF LOCAL AIR
QUALITY NEEDS AND CONDITIONS
THIS BILL ABANDONS THAT
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH BY REQUIRING
AIR DISTRICTS TO ESTABLISH
UNIFORM PERMITTING PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THEIR
DISTRICTS FOR ON DEMAND TANK
VEHICLE OPERATIONS INCLUDING
SETTING UNIFORM NEW SOURCE
REVIEW STANDARDS. THIS ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH IS ACTUALLY
COUNTER TO CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR ACT MANDATES
REQUIRING AIR DISTRICTS TO
IMPLEMENT PERMITTING AND NEW
SOURCE REVIEW RULES THAT TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT LOCAL REGIONAL AIR
QUALITY NEEDS AND REQUIREMENTS.
IN EFFECT UNDER THIS BILL A
SMALLER AIR DISTRICT LIKE MODOC
WITH A POPULATION OF AROUND TEN
THOUSAND. WOULD EITHER HAVE TO
GO ABOUT THIS THE SAME AS SAN
DIEGO. OR ALTERNATIVELY SAN
DIEGO WOULD HAVE TO GO ABOUT
THINGS THE SAME WAY AS MODOC.
FOUR IT WOULD BE SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN WHICH CAN LOWER PUBLIC
HEALTH PROTECTION DEPENDING ON
THE AIR DISTRICT. IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE. MEMBERS THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE AND PROCESS IS WORKING
AS INTENDED BOOSTER FUELS IS
OPERATING IN MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST AIR
DISTRICTS INCLUDING THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. SACRAMENTO AREA SAN
DIEGO VENTURE AS WELL AS PLASTER
COLLECTIVELY THESE AIR DISTRICTS
COMPRISE CLOSE TO EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION YET. THIS IS THE
THIRD YEAR OF BOOSTER FUELS. ONE
COMPANY. COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE ASKING FOR SPECIAL
TREATMENT. AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE BOOSTER FUELS TO
ENGAGE INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS IN
WHICH THEY WANT TO OPERATE
INSTEAD OF PURSUING POLICIES
THAT ARE DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU KNOW VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
VOICE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE. I
SEE ONE COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE THING TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. C. THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RUSSELL RAWLINGS I AM THE
STATE WIDE COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
AT CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
FACILITATOR OF THE DISABILITY
ORGANIZING NETWORK OR DO YOU
NETWORK AN ORGANIZATION ARE A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION THAT
PUSHES FOR PUBLIC POLICY CHANGES
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES I
STATEWIDE AND AS A NEW VEHICLE
OWNER MYSELF AND SOMEONE WHO'S
GOING TO DRIVING PROCESS I
SUPPORT AT. THE A PROPOSED
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE G.
HONEST CITY DAY WITH BROWN STEEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANY HARGROVE ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR. ANYBODY WISHING
TO VOICE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE.
OPERATOR THERE. YES I'M HERE I
APOLOGIZE LINE SIXTY EIGHT YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. MMHM YES. I MEAN
JENNIFER COMMITTEE ON MINE I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIANS FOR SMART
FEELING COALITION THE PERSON
WITH A DISABILITY I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
THREE BECAUSE DRIVERS WITH
DISABILITIES DESERVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO FUEL THEIR VIEW JUST
JUST NAME AND AN ORGANIZATION IF
YOU SUPPORTER DON'T SUPPORT
PLEASE FOR ALL OF THE CALLERS ON
THE PHONE X. COLOR PLEASE THANK
YOU. JENNIFER COMMITTEE ON A-
NEXT LINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
GENERAL HELLO THE GOVERNMENT FOR
IN FAVOR AND. AND. TWENTY
PERFECT THANK YOU NEXT LINE STEP
FOUR PLAY GO AHEAD. MICRONATIONS
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS I'M A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE THANK YOU. AND NO
OTHER LINES CAN YOU MAY PROCEED
. THANK YOU WILL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER GIBSON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I TRY NOT TO SPEAK
ON EVERY BILL THE SPECIAL BILLS-
LIKE I TRY NOT TO DO THAT BUT
CERTAINLY- I WANT TO ASK THE
FIRST WELL THE ONE THING THE
OFFICE FOR BRING THIS BILL
BEFORE US I KNOW THAT- THAT-
THIS IS A WAY TO ONE GUY AND GET
AND USE THE TIMES MOBILE FUELING
I THINK IT REALLY SPEAKS OF THE
MODERN DAY IN THE TECHNOLOGY WE
HAVE AVAILABLE AND IT ALSO
PROVIDES I THINK OF THE- FOR
THOSE WHO'VE TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF. THE ABILITY TO- TO
MEET PEOPLE RIGHT WHERE THEY'RE
RIGHT WHERE THEY ARE- WHETHER
PEOPLE HAVE DISABILITIES OR
WHATEVER IT CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE- THEIR THEIR
NEEDS BEING MET- BECAUSE WE GO
TO FILLING STATION- THEY'RE NOT
BEING MET BASED ON WHAT THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER IN SUPPORT OF
INDUSTRY- ILLUSTRATED SO I WOULD
ASK THE AUTHOR THIS BILL IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I THINK THIS BRINGS US
INTO AN AGE WHERE. WE SHOULD
LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES OF TRYING
TO MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES BETTER
LIVE VIEW THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR WARD. THANK YOU I'M
REALLY PURSUE THE AUTHOR BRING
THIS FOR AND I SERIOUSLY
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO BE ABLE PROMOTE
HERE AND THAT SAID IT FEELS LIKE
IT'S RUNNING COUNTER TO WHERE I
WOULD HOPE THINGS ARE GOING LONG
MORE LONGER RANGE- PARTICULARLY
AS WE'RE TRYING TO WEAN OFF OF
FOSSIL FUELS- I UNDERSTAND THIS
IS AMY- POTENTIAL APPLICATION
THAT COULD MOVE TOWARD
ALTERNATIVE FUELS YET IT IT
SEEMS THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
AUTHORIZING THE- DELIVERY ANY
ADMINISTRATION OF GASOLINE- AND
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT HERE IN THE IN
THE BILL ITSELF. AND SO COUPLE
THINGS ONE- I A I AM
FUNDAMENTALLY IS SYMPATHETIC AND
I AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO FIND
OUT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THOSE WITH CHALLENGES OR OTHER
OTHER DISABILITIES. WHO ARE
HAVING ACCESS ISSUES RIGHT NOW
BUT THIS WOULD PROGRAM WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY BE LIMITED TO
INDIVIDUALS OF THOSE CHALLENGES.
RIGHT THIS WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
EVERYBODY TO USE YEAH THE ONE OF
THE PRIMARY- CASES WOULD BE
FLEETS. I AM VERY YEARS INSTEAD
OF HAVING HUNDREDS OF CARS GO TO
A STATION YOU HAVE ONE- ONE TANK
ONE TANK COME AROUND AND FEEL
ALL THE CARS THEREFORE REDUCE
THE MILES TRAVELED- AND ALSOAS
YOU SAID IT'S NOT JUST RIGHT
NOW. THEY HAVE TAKEN ALL OF
THEIR DIESEL CUSTOMERS AND
BROUGHT THEM OVER POSTER FEELS
HAS OVER TO RENEWABLE DIESEL IS
ALREADY OPERATING IN THE
ALTERNATIVE FUEL SPACE. AND YOU
HEARD THE HYDROGEN COALITION
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF EARLY CAN
HAVE A COUPLE HUNDRED HYDROGEN
STATIONS AS A HYDROGEN CAR USER
I WOULD REALLY LOVE TO HAVE THIS
OPTION. I CAN APPRECIATE THAT IN
TODAY'S DYNAMIC SIDE LIKE TO SEE
DOWN THE ROAD HOW WE ARE ME
TRANSFORMING A LOT OF OUR GOT
THE SENSORS WHICH HAVE ALREADY
BEEN SORT OF DEVELOPED. NOT
PERFECTLY BUT GENERALLY TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT CONSUMER
NEED WITH THE DISTRIBUTION AND
SORT OF THE- THE- THE HOW THINGS
ARE SORT OF LAID OUT YOU KNOW ON
THE MAP- AND I HOPE THAT WHETHER
IT'S EASY OR HYDROGEN THAT THOSE
WILL ALSO BECOME POINTS OF SALE
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL. AND UNTIL
THAT TIME IS FOR FILL IN THAT
GAP I COULD SEE THIS BEING
USEFUL BUT BUT IS NOT LIMITED I
FEEL AS THOUGH IF THIS WERE IN
PLACE NEXT YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE YOU KNOW HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF TANKERS JUST
TRAVELING. RESIDENTIAL AND OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS AROUND THE STEAM
IT IT IT I I'M WORRIED THAT WELL
CAN INDUCE- SOME MORE PROBLEMS
THAN IN SOME OF THE- BENEFITS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE.
WELL I THINK IT WOULD IN FACT.
GIVE YOU MORE BENEFITS ARE I
WOULDN'T BE UP HERE- LOOK
ALREADY 80% OF THE POPULATION
DOES HAVE ACCESS TO THIS BUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING THE OTHER
TWENTY PERCENT. THE ANSWER IS
IT'S UNREGULATED. FELLOW IF
THURSDAY ARE EXEMPTION FOR
SMALLER. VEHICLE DELIVERIES WHAT
IS IT HOW MANY GALLONS. A
RANGERS FROM USUALLY ONE TWENTY
TO TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY GALLONS
YEAH SO IF YOU'RE- IN A- PICKUP
TRUCK AND YOU HAVE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY GALLONS. YOU CAN FUEL
ANYWHERE YOU WANT AND WHAT KEPCO
HAS SAID AND I AGREE WITH THEM
THIS COULD THIS IS DANGEROUS. ON
THE OTHER HAND BOOSTER FUELS IS
ALLOWED TO OPERATE BOTH IN THE
BAY AREA. AND IN THE SOUTH COAST
AND THE REASON THEY'RE WHO
HELPED OPERATE IS THEY DON'T
HAVE THIS PROBLEM. THE SMALLER
OPERATORS DO AND YET THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO OPERATE AND BOOSTER
FUELS IS NOT SO I THINK WE HAVE
TO BRING THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TECH OUR CLEAN AIR TECHNOLOGIES
FOR THE WHOLE STATE. AND NOT
JUST ALLOW- PEOPLE WHO ARE YOU
NOT HAVE THESE TECHNOLOGIES TO
BE OUT THERE. ARE FUELING UNLESS
THE AIR DISTRICT ITSELF FIVE
THERE'S A WAY TO DO IT NOW ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS ARE
BROUGHT UP HERE TODAY IS WE'RE
WILLING. SELECT AIR DISTRICTS.
FROM UP WITH THEIR OWN
REGULATION AS LONG AS IT FITS.
LONG AS IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
DOING THE RIGHT THING FROM THE
POINT OF VIEW OF ENVIRONMENT AND
NOT ALLOWING THESE GASES. TO
POLLUTE THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TODAY SO
THIS IS AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
SOMETHING TO BRING THE REST OF
THE STATE UP TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS THAT ARE
NEEDED. I WANT TO NEGOTIATE WITH
CAP COLA SO THAT EACH OF THOSE
DISTRICTS. AND SET UP THEIR OWN
RULES AND WE CAN WORK ON HOW THE
BILL IS STATED. WE CAN WORK ON
THE TIME LINE. BUT THAT'S MY
INTENT THAT WILL MAKE THIS A
CLEANER HEALTHIER AIR FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE THANK YOU DR
PARK AND I KNOW THAT YOU WOULD
DO THAT AS AN AUTHOR AS WELL I'D
LIKE TO HEAR SOME MORE COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES I'M JUST NOT.
VISIONING IT RIGHT NOW- BUT I'D
LIKE TO SEE HOW THIS- HOW THIS
PLAYSOUT. YOU'RE MY FRIEND
ANYWAY. MISTER KALRA THANK YOU
ADAM CHEN THANK YOU SUMMER A
CORK ON ON THAT LAST POINT
BECAUSE I DID SERVE ON THE COURT
YOUR CALL MATCH DISTRICT BOARD
SO I DEFINITELY- I UNDERSTAND
AND RESPECT THE NEED FOR
INDIVIDUAL JURISDICTIONS TO HAVE
SOME SUCH FROM NATION- AND SO.
IF BUT I'LL AND I ALSO VERY MUCH
KNOW HOW YOU OPERATE AND TRIED
TO- WORK TO FIND COMMON GROUND
AND FIND TO- WEBER THERE ARE
COMMON GOALS- BUT- TO TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO BRING THEM
TOGETHER AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
AND SO ON THAT POINT IN TERMS
OF. RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH UNREGULATED PART OF IT LIKE
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE UNREGULATED
PICKUP TRUCKS RUNNING AROUND IS
FILLING UP. THAT'S NOT TENABLE-
AND OF THE OTHER ASPECT OF IT
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY WHICH IS A GOOD
THING AS I'VE SEEN A COUPLE GAS
STATIONS CLOSE- I THINK WE
NEEDED. THAT WOULD BE GREAT IF
WE SEE MORE OF THOSE HAPPEN OF
COURSE AS YOU KNOW THE GAS
STATIONS IN THEMSELVES- TAKEN
NORMA'S AMOUNT OF RESOURCES TO
CLEAN UP ONCE THEY CLOSE OR WHAT
HAVE YOU. AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
CITY COUNCIL WE HAD OUR FIRST.
HYDROGEN STATION I THINK IT'S
ALMOST TEN YEARS I THINK WE
STILL ONLY HAVE THAT ONE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE- AND SO I'M VERY
INTRIGUED BY THE- FUTURE
APPLICATIONS CERTAINLY OF MOBILE
HYDROGEN. WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY THE KIND OF THE GOLDEN
TICKET SO TO SPEAK OF THIS KIND
OF TECHNOLOGY WHERE YOU CAN
REALLY- EXPAND. UPON THIS IS A
RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGY BASICALLY
GREEN HYDROGEN OF COURSE- TO GET
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITIES- AND DO
YOU BUT I GUESS THE QUESTION A
DOCTOR CORK IS- ARE THAT. YOU
YOU MENTIONED TRYING TO WORK
WITH OF CAPITAL AND WHAT HAVE
YOU- ARE THERE. THE OTHER AREAS
YOU THINK- IS THERE A MIDDLE
GROUND THAT YOU CAN GET TO YOU
BELIEVE IN THIS REGARD- I DO
BELIEVE THAT- KEPCO MAY NOT BUT
LOOK I'M WILLING TO SAY EACH
DISTRICT WILL SET ITS OWN
STANDARDS BUT IT CAN'T ALLOW.
THESE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
GALLON. OUR PEOPLE POLLUTING THE
AIR AT THE SAME TIME NOT ALLOW
MOBILE FUELING WHICH HAS ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION IN THIS
TO ME IS A REAL CONTRADICTION
AND IT EXISTS IN THE 20% OF THE
STATE THAT'S NOT ALLOWING. SO I
WANT TO WORK WITH THEM. TO WORK
ON TIME LINES WE CAN WORK ON
WHAT THE STANDARD IS- BUT WE CAN
GO FROM THERE IS THE MOBILE.
PUMPING IS AS THE SUMMER WORE
INDICATING LIKE GOING OUT TO
COMMUNITIES AND PUMPING WHETHER
IT'S FLEAS OR OTHERWISE DOES
THAT. POSE A SIMILAR PROBLEM TO
KNOW TO FOLKS THAT ARE POPPING
UP AT THE GAS STATION OR IS
THERE A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
THOSE KINDS OF THAT CONDUCT WELL
WHY DON'T YOU- I'LL HAVE MY
EXPERTISE. A SERVICE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION YOU KNOW AS WITH ANY
INDUSTRY THAT IS NEW- THERE ARE-
THIS IS IN THE EARLY STAGE OF
POLICY DEVELOPMENTS- RIGHT NOW.
AND THERE'S BASICALLY TWO BROAD
CATEGORIES OF REGULATION ONE IS
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE HERE
DISCUSSING. ONE IS FROM. THE
FIRE SAFETY SIDE ON THE FIRE
SAFETY SIDE- A NEWS SECTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CODE. STOP
ME FROM GOING TO THE BUT IT'S A
START WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
FIRE CODE WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FOLLOWS IN THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CODE. THE ADOPTED SECTION
FIFTY SEVEN OH SEVEN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WHICH LIMITS THE USAGE
OF MOBILE FEELING AND TO THAT
QUICK POINT. THE REASON THAT
THIS BILL IS ALWAYS HAD THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS IS BECAUSE THE PICKUP
TRUCK SIDE OF THE INDUSTRY AS
WE'RE CALLING IT. HAS BEEN
OPERATING AND COMPLETE FLAGRANT
VIOLATION OF FIRE COLD ALL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. INCLUDING
ON RESIDENTIAL STREET WHICH IS
PROHIBITED. SO RIGHT NOW THE
BASIC REQUIREMENTS FROM A FIRE
CODE PERSPECTIVE ARE A CITY IN
AND OF ITSELF MAY DECIDE THAT IT
DOESN'T WANT TO ADOPTED IN THE
FIRE CODE. OPERATE SO THERE ARE
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAD
MAY BE INDEPENDENT OF SUCH AND
WE JUST DON'T WANT MOBILE
FEELING SO CITIES DO HAVE THAT
POWER. B. ARE YOU MUST BE TEN
FEET AWAY FROM ANY BUILDING YOU
CANNOT FUEL ON PUBLIC STREETS.
AND YOU MUST BE TEN FEET AWAY
FROM ANY OF PROPERTY LINE SO. TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARDS CONCERN
WHICH WELL I DO UNDERSTAND I
HEAR TO HEAR THAT A LOT- THEY-
THE FIRE. CODE GEN- ALLEN'S
HABIT THAT WE COME UP WITH A
SYSTEM THAT HAVE TRIED TO REDUCE
ANY SORT OF REST BY MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S NEVER GOING TO BE A
MOBILE FEWER. ON THE STREET
WHILE IT'S CONDUCTING FUELING.
BUT TO THE SAFETY POINT. THE
PROCESS THAT MOLECULAR LIKE
BOOSTER HAVE GONE THROUGH IT
TOOK THREE YEARS OF ENGAGING
WITH CARB. TO HAVE OUR TANKERS
DOT TESTED PRESSURE TESTED
ROLLOVER TESTED FIRE TESTED
CRASH PROOF. THEY SET A ROUTE
WHERE ADS AGAIN ON THE OTHER
SIDE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
ANYWHERE FROM A HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY GALLONS OF
GASOLINE AND DIFFERENT
CONTAINERS THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
LEVEL OF PROTECTIONS. AND THAT'S
WHERE THE TRUTH THROUGH THE TRUE
DANGER LIES BUT IN TERMS OF
WHERE WE CAN OPERATE IT IS TEN
TIMES THE B. AND COMMERCIAL- OR
INDUSTRIAL AREAS NOT YET IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS DUE TO THOSE
LIMITATIONS- UNDER THE FIRE
CODE. THANK YOU. I HAVE A
QUESTION- FIRST OF ALL I%
APPRECIATE YOUR- TIME THIS IS
THE GERMAN FROM WORCESTER I
APPRECIATE YOUR MEETING WITH ME
ON THE BILL- I AM CURIOUS AS TO.
OF YOUR CURRENT CUSTOMER BASE
HOW MANY OF THEM ARE THE
DIFFERENTLY ABLED POPULATION
THAT IS ACCESS ISSUES AND HOW
DOES THE PRICING STRUCTURE WORK.
FOR THEM SURE SO. THE ANSWER IS
DIFFERENT IN CALIFORNIA THAN IN
OTHER PLACES BECAUSE OF PROBABLY
NOT SURPRISINGLY- YOU KNOW WE
OPERATE IN PLACES LIKE TEXAS AND
TENNESSEE WHERE FROM A
REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE IT'S A
LOT IT'S A LOT EASIER. I DON'T
KNOW WE HAVE EXACT NUMBERS ON
THE PERCENTAGE OF OUR CLIENTELE
THAT ARE THAT ARE- DISABLE
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T ASKED THAT
QUESTION BUT I DO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE. BEEN ABLE TO HAVE A LOT
MORE EVENTS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY CATERED TO PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND OTHER
JURISDICTIONS PRIMARILY
WASHINGTON STATE AND IN TEXAS
AND IN FACT. IF YOU HAPPEN TO
TAKE A LOOK AT ABU SAYS WEBSITE
YOU'LL SEE INFORMATION ABOUT-
THE BENTLEY DID A FEW MONTHS AGO
AND DALLAS TEXAS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CALL A POP UP
GAS STATION. WHERE AS OPPOSED TO
EITHER COMING TO YOUR WORKPLACE
AND FINDING YOUR CAR WITH MOBILE
FEELING YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ESSENTIALLY FIND A PARKING LOT.
POSTUP A MOBILE TANKER SET UP
SOME CONES AND PEOPLE CAN DRIVE
THROUGH WITHOUT EVER LEAVING
THEIR CAR. AND GET FUEL YEAH I'M
TRYING TO DO THIS IN LA A COUPLE
OF MONTHS AGO BUT AGAIN DUE TO
REGULATIONS WE WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO SO WE HAVE THOSE HAS
OPERATIONS IN OTHER STATES BUT
DUE TO SOME OF THE REGULATORY
CHALLENGES IT'S BEEN A LOT LESS
SO HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
TO YOUR PRICING QUESTION. ON THE
CONSUMER SIDE THIS IS SEPARATE
FROM THE FLEAS BECAUSE FOR
FLEETS WE WILL CHARGE SERVICE
FEES BUT IF IT'S A CONSUMER
BASED SERVICE OVER OTHER COMING
TO YOUR PLACE OF WORK OR DOING A
POP UP. ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE DO
IS WE TAKE THE AVERAGE OF THE
FIVE CLOSEST GAS STATIONS
AVERAGE OUT THOSE PRICES AND
THAT IS THE MOST THAT WILL
OFFER. SOMETIMES FOR VANS WE
HAVE DONE YOU KNOW WILL DO
COUPONS ARE WILL DO REDUCE THE
COST WILL BE NEVER DO AN UP
CHARGE THERE'S NO SERVICE FEE.
THE MOST WILL EVER CHARGE TO THE
DIRECTLY TO THE CONSUMER IS THE
AVERAGE OF THE FIVE CLOSEST GAS
STATIONS OKAY SO IF I'M HEARING
YOU THIS YOU REALLY HAVEN'T
DONE. OF FEELING FOR THIS
POPULATION AS A SURLY YET IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD INTEND TO DO IN
THE FUTURE WE HAVE DONE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN
EVENT COMING UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS
BUT AGAIN IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING.
NOT ONLY DO THE REGULATIONS BUT. FRANKLY- YOU KNOW COVERED WITH
NOT. AND WE HAD TO. OUT A WHOLE
NEW MATH OF OPERATE. THE WAY WE
WORK THE WAY WE WERE DELIVERING
IT TO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
WAS AT THE WORK PLACE AND IN
FACT. THAT'S WHERE WE STARTED
GETTING THE FEEDBACK ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THIS WAS TO PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. OVERHEAD
PEOPLE STOP GOING TO WORK AND
THEN WE WERE NOT THAT'S WHEN WE
STARTED BUILDING UP A FLEET
BUSINESS SIDE BUT THAT'S ALSO
WHERE WE CAME UP WITH THE IDEA
OF THE PUBLIC GAS STATION WHICH
WE WERE ABLE TO MORE QUICKLY
TEST. IN PLACES LIKE DALLAS AND
WASHINGTON AND NOW THAT WE KNOW
THAT THAT WORKS WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING TO BRING IT MORE TO
CALIFORNIA. GOT IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SO MISTER CORK IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SURE. I JUST
WANT TO ASK MY EXPERTS SO ARE
THERE HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF
DISABLED PEOPLE GETTING FUEL
FROM YOU. MISTER PROXIMATE I
WOULD SAY. I WOULD SAY OVER THE
YEARS WE HAD THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE. ACROSS THE COUNTRY
GETTING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA THE IT'S
BEEN LESS BUT I WOULD SAY THAT'S
BEEN OVER AT LEAST IT'S IN THE
THOUSANDS BUT- I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT OVER THE YEARS. ALL
RIGHT JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GOT THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION.
LOOK THIS IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL.
DEL IF WE CAN GO FORWARD AND
AGAIN I'M GOING TO WORK WITH CAP
COLA. AND MAKE SURE THAT EACH
DISTRICT AND HAVE ITS OWN SAY ON
THIS AND WE'LL WORK ON WHAT THAT
STANDARD IS. WORK ON WHAT THE
TIME LINE IS. ARMED I DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH THAT THAT'S WHY
WE CHANGE THE BILL FROM LAST
YEAR WHERE IT WAS GOING TO BE
TOP DOWN. THEY OBJECTED WE SAID
ALRIGHT YOU HAVE COMPLETE
AUTHORITY. NOW ARE ASKING IS
PLEASE EXERCISE THAT AUTHORITY
PLEASE HAVE RULES. RULES THAT
WILL MEET THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
AIR POLLUTION STANDARDS. AND
RULES THAT ALREADY THE BAY AREA
ON THE SOUTH COAST OF SAID YEAH
THOSE ARE GOOD ENOUGH. SO WE
THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO WE THINK THIS IS A POSSIBLE
THING TO DO. I'M WILLING TO FIND
OUT IF MODOC OR- ANOTHER AGENCY
HAS A PARTICULAR PROBLEM. OF BUT
- THIS WILL REDUCE POLLUTION IN
THE STATE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL THEN DR KIRK HAS
BEEN HE HAS BEEN. VERY VERY
THOUGHTFUL EXTREMELY RESPONSIVE
IN ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS
EXTREMELY FLEXIBLE. AND IN TILL
THIS BILL CAME FORWARD IT DIDN'T
OCCUR TO ME THAT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE FULL SERVICE STATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH A BARRIER
THAT CAN BE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIFFERENTLY ABLED- AS OPPOSED TO
YOU KNOW NEW JERSEY WHERE I
THINK THEY ALL HAVE TO BE FULL
SERVICE. I WHICH I PERSONALLY
LIKE BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE DO
HERE. SO YOU KNOW IT WAS A REAL-
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY FOR ME AS
WELL- TO HEAR ABOUT THAT AND I
DO THINK THAT THE- THE HYDROGEN.
A CONCEPT YOU KNOW IF IT MOVES
INTO THE FUTURE AND YOU'RE ABLE
TO TECHNICALLY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO IT- ALSO FFER. OFFERS A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITIES NOW THE REASON
I'M A NOT ON THIS BILL TODAY IS
BECAUSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN CHANGE AND MÀ AND- AMENDED
SO MUCH DUE TO OUR CONCERNS IS
REALLY MUCH MORE OF WITH IN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES JURISDICTION.
SO THAT'S WHERE I THINK A LOT OF
YOU'RE REALLY GOING TO BE
GETTING INTO THE MEAT OF HOW
THIS IS GOING TO WORK WITH THE-
DISTRICTS IS REALLY GOING TO BE
WORKED ON THAT'S OUT OF OUR-
JURISDICTION HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE. SO I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY- I'M GONNA
RESERVE WHAT MY OPINION FOR THE
WHEN IT MOVES INTO NATURAL
RESOURCES. BUT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR FLEXIBILITY AND AGAIN YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS ON THE BILL WITH
THAT CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE. DO PASTERNAK RESOURCES
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE
FONG I BERMAN HI BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM DALY HI DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON AYE
GIPSON AYE KALRA KALRA I LEE.
MEDINA MEDINA NOT VOTING. THIS
AREA. WHEN O'DONNELL WARD. WICKS
WIXII EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU
THAT'LL IS OUT. WE'RE MOVING NOW
TO A AB TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO BY
MISTER RAMOS. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND AND A THIRTY MAY
COME IN ORDERS THAT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY JAMES KEEPING IN
MIND THAT YOU HAVE A SECOND AND
A THIRD. YOU MAY WANT TO TEMPER
YOUR COMMENTS. RIDLEY.
AND YOU JUST NEED TO PUSH THE
BUTTON. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE MOTION AND SEVERAL
SECONDS ON THE BILL- THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE WOULD CLARIFY
THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES CAN SHARE LPR DATA
WITHOUT WITHOUT OF STATE OR
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO LOCATE A VEHICLE OR PERSON.
RESPONSIBLY RESPOND REASONABLY
SUSPECTED OF BEING INVOLVED IN
THE COMMISSION OF A PUBLIC
OFFENSE WE DID- WORK ON TAKING
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT CLARIFIED
ADDITIONALLY THAT AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO WOULD ALSO CLARIFY
THAT. LPR DATA CANNOT BE SHARED
IT WOULD VIOLATE THE CALIFORNIA
VALUES ACT- WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD AND WORK WITH THOSE
AND STAKEHOLDERS OF FINDING A
BALANCE WITHIN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. WITH ME TODAY IS
WITH THE STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION COREY SAYS ILLEGAL.
HEY LET'S GO TO YOUR WITNESSES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CORY CELLS ALONG BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- IN LIGHT OF THE
COMMITTEES TIME AND THE MULTIPLE
EXPRESSIONS OF. HAVING THE BILL
PROCEED I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK- THE
AUTHOR SAID IT VERY WELL WERE
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
MEMBERS TO MAKE SURE WE FIND A
BALANCE BETWEEN. MOTORISTS
PRIVACY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
ABILITY TO USE THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL WITH RECOGNITIONS
ABOUT CONCERNS OF THE COMMITTEE-
ANDOPPOSITION BROUGHT FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE ARE TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND SO WE MAY VERY
WELL COME BACK TO YOU WITH
QUESTIONS- WE HAVE TRACY
ROSENBERG FROM THE OAKLAND
PRIVACY IN MEDIA ALLIANCE AND%
SIERRA HUSSEIN FROM THE
pELECTRONIC FUND. FRONTIER
FOUNDATION I'M NOT SURE IF
THEY'RE IN THE ROOM OR BY PHONE
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE BY PHONE SO
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE FIND
OUR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND-
TWO MINUTES APIECE PLEASE THANK
YOU. THEIR LINES ARE OPEN.
MEMBERS HAS BEEN ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECT CARE PENSION IN WITH
OPPOSITION WELL WE HAVE SHE
THREE AMENDMENTS MADE ADDRESS
SOME ARKANSAS ABOUT THE BUT JUST
. EVEN AND THEN FAILED TO
PREVENT AUTOMATED LICENSE PATE
READER OR LPR INFORMATION FROM
ENDING UP IN THE WRONG HANDS
PUTTING GREAT RISK TO PRIVACY
AND CIVIL LIBERTIES OF
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES FROM SHARING
ALE PR INFORMATION WITH OUT OF
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING AGENCIES IMMIGRATION
AND CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT. IS A
CRUCIAL TO PROTECTING THE
PRIVACY OF IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT I HAVE BEEN
USING LPR INFORMATION TO LOCATE
DETAIN AND DEPORT IMMIGRANTS AT
LEAST TWENTY NINETEEN. AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY TWO WOULD UNDERMINE
AND PUT IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS
IN HARM'S WAY. EVEN WOULD BE
AMENDED BILLS REFERENCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA VALUES ACT THE BILL
WOULD STILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES TO PASS ON A L. P. R.
INFORMATION CHECK OUT OF STATE
AGENCIES. EASILY SHARE THAT A-
ON WHERE TO. WHEN I TELL AGENTS
EVERY ABOUT IT. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO UNDERMINE TELEPHONE STATUS
AS A SANCTUARY FOR PEOPLE
SEEKING ABORTION AND GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. JUST AS WITH THE
I THINK DOUBLE ONE CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES RELEASED LPR
INFORMATION OUT OF STATE. THAT
INFORMATION CAN EASILY BE
TRANSMITTED ONWARD TO
GOVERNMENTS THAT CRIMINALIZE
ABORTION AND GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE. MOREOVER THE AMENDED BILL
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA AGENCIES TO
ANALYZE AND BE CONSTANTLY
APPRISED OF THE LAWS GOVERNING
POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS OF LPR
DATA. TO BE REQUIRING CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES TO BECOME ARBITERS OF
THE LEGAL RIGHT OF ABORTION
SEEKERS THE L. G. B. T. Q.
PEOPLE. IN THE CONTEXT OF
DRIVERS AROUND. IT IS BOTH AN
INAPPROPRIATE AND IMPRACTICAL
SITUATION FOR CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER AGENCIES
TO KEEP TRACK OF COMPLICATED AND
EVER CHANGING LAWS OUTSIDE OF
THEIR JURISDICTION. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE A
NO VOTE ON AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN THANK. YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. I MY IS
TRACY. ROSENBERG I'M SPEAKING ON
. OF OPEN PRIVACY HAVE WORKED
WITH MUNICIPALITIES ALL OVER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ON THERE A.
L. P. R. POLICIES. TO KEEP. THE
DATA SAFE AND SECURE AS POSSIBLE
UNFORTUNATELY THE CHANGES TO THE
CURRENT LAW. AB. TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO. THANK WE WILL DO THE
OPPOSITE MOST OF THE FANS BY
OVER TWO FIFTY. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE STORED IN PRIVATELY
OWNED CLOUD IT IT IT DATABASES
DATA IS SHARED BY ALLOWING ONE
AGENCY IN THIS CASE AN OUT OF
STATE ONE TO QUERY AUTOMATICALLY
. ANOTHER AGENCIES THE DATABASE
MUST CALIFORNIA AGENCIES HAVE
HUNDREDS OF OTHER AGENCIES WITH
ACCESS. TO THEIR ACCOUNT IN THE
CLASS AGENCIES IN OTHER STATES
MUST FOLLOW THE POLICY. AND LAWS
ARE ON THEIR OWN STATES NOT TO
CALIFORNIA AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO AS AMENDED PROPOSES THAT
EACH OF CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MONITOR
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS ACROSS.
FIFTY OTHER STATES AND THEN
COULD YOU THEIR ENTIRE SHARING
LIST OF WHAT COULD BE DOZENS OF
INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES LOCATED IN
THAT STATE THERE IS NO PRACTICAL
WAY FOR THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYTHING WILL AGENCY GOES
THROUGH THIS PROCESS EVERY
SINGLE TIME AND NO PRACTICAL WAY
TO ENSURE THAT THE SHARING IS IN
FACT CUT OFF THE EACH AND EVERY.
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA TO EACH AND
EVERY. AGENCY TAXES. WAR IDAHO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT NO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. MORE
FULLY COMPLIANT WITH AOP OUR
PRIVACY LAWS THAT WERE PASSED
OVER SEVEN YEARS. AGO AT A TIME
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IS
ENTERTAINING NUMEROUS DETAILS ON
THE SUBJECTS OF. REPRODUCTIVE
PRIVACY THE RIGHT TO USE MEDICAL
CARE AND SANCTUARY. AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY TWO WILL UNDER CRIED
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THEM TAKE
YOUR TIME OUR TIME TO YOUR TIME
IS UP PLEASE IF YOU CAN FINISH.
WHAT'S WORSE LET IT IS NOT
POSSIBLE TO RESTRICT OUT OF
STATE AGENCY IS A CALIFORNIA'S
ANPR DATA SOLELY. TO USES THAT
ARE COMPLIANT WITH CALIFORNIA
LAW THANK YOU FOR CALLING STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALIFORNIA
VALUES. OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO. SEEING NONE THE
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WE FIRST GO TO LINE
TWENTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
BAKER KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT WE GO TO LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SEVENTY GO AHEAD- YES MY NAME IS
LIU CALVES I'M IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND AND I'M OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO. LINE
SEVENTY THREE IS NEXT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JADI WITH OAKLAND
CREDITANDREW CONTEC OPPOSING AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR COMMITMENT FROM
BERKELEY I'M WITH RACISM AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM GROUP
AND I'M OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO THANK. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE SIXTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION. AND MEDICARE NO
OTHER LINE THANK YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
GONNA TAKE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS WORKS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I JUST WANNA- ONE I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S AMENDING
THE BILL AND TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION I'M CAN I SPOKE
TODAY HE'S GIVEN HIS WORD HE'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OPPOSITION IS RAISED- I
ALSO SO THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE-
AND PRIVACY IS. IMPORTANT PART
OF MY VALUE AND I KNOW MANY OF
MY CONSTITUENTS- SO I'M GONNA
GIVE THIS A COURTESY AYE VOTE
TODAY TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME TO SEE IF YOU CAN COME
TO SOME KIND OF AGREEMENT WITH
THEM WITH THE- THE COPY AT THAT
I'M I MIGHT NOT SUPPORT THE BILL
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE IF YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO WORK OUT
THOSE DIFFERENCES BUT OUT OF
RESPECT YOU WANT TO GIVE YOU
THAT TIME TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD. BUT I DO SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
I'M ALSO HAPPY TO BE A PART OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS IF I CAN BE
HELPFUL ANYWAY BUT ALL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY TO GIVE YOU A BIT
MORE TIME MORE ON MY HERE. THANK
YOU MISTER WARD THANK YOU ALL
AND YOUR STOMACH'S GONNA
COMPLETELY ECO CONCERN OVER
WEEKS COMMENTS WELL APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION WE HAD EARLIER
TODAY AND I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO
WATCH THE IMPROVEMENTS ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH. PRESSURE
FONG. BUT LET ME SAY THAT- I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE AUTHORS
TRYING TO DO IN SOME WAYS PUBLIC
SAFETY HAS A- VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION BECAUSE SHARING OF
INFORMATION. IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT WE'RE CONNECTING
THE DOTS. AND TRYING TO PREVENT.
A BAD THINGS ARE HAPPENING- I AM
COMING IN FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAT BIFURCATING- IN
CERTAIN STATES. THAT YOU CAN
TALK TO IN CERTAIN STATES YOU
CAN'T TALK TO. AND AGENCIES CAN
TALK TO AGES YOU CAN'T TALK TO
YOU. ABOUT THAT IS IT IT'S
PROBLEMATIC TO ME BECAUSE- THE
IN THE DAY. WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT TRYING TO PREVENT-
YOU KNOW HEINOUS ACTS ARE
HAPPENING POTENTIALLY AND
ENSURING THAT THERE IS FREE
FLOWING INFORMATION- IS CRITICAL
SO FOR THAT REASON I'M GONNA LAY
OFF TODAY AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. MISTER KALRA THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND I APPRECIATE
YOU REACHING OUT EARLIER TODAY I
DID GET A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE
MEMBERS I I'D STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS REGARDING- THE SHARING
OF THE DATA PARTICULARLY. WITH
OTHER STATES- AND IF I MAY BE
THE OPPOSITE APPROACH FOR THE
OPPOSITE ANGLE AS OUR CALL THE
SERVER FONG. BUT IT AND SO- I
MAYBE AM LAY OFF TODAY BUT I DO-
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS- WHEN AB
YOU KNOW IF IT GOES TO PRIVACY
AND COMES TO THE FLOOR- BUT- YOU
KNOW HIS AS A FOR A PUBLIC
DEFENDER I HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS WHEN DATA STARTS TO
MOVE QUICKLY ACROSS STATE LINES-
WHEN- WELL YOU KNOW I THINK WE
GENERALLY HAVE MORE RESPECT FOR
THE PRIVACY OF. OF THOSE THAT
GET CAUGHT UP IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I ALSO HAVE A
VERY- KIND OF- I GUESS IF HE OF
THE MY NOT CRITICALLY WELL RIGHT
NOW UP SENSE OF PLACES PLACE
READERS IN GENERAL WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THAT DATA. AND SO- WITH THE
BENEFIT OF TIME BY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK SOME MORE
AND HOPEFULLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET ON BOARD AS
PARTICULARLY WITH CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH SOME OF THE- THE
OPPOSITION ON THE PRIVACY SIDE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I DON'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE PUBLIC MY
COMMENTS- I THINK THIS IS KIND
OF A TOUGH BILL- TOUGH BUT
IMPORTANT I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A PUBLIC SAFETY BENEFIT
TO SHARING THIS INFORMATION AND
IF THERE WAS SOMEONE WHO WAS A
FUGITIVE WHO IS DANGEROUS WHO
HAD COMMITTED A HEINOUS CRIME OF
COURSE I WOULD WANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO USE
ALL THE RESOURCES THAT THEY HAD
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE LAW AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD SHARE
INFORMATION WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
OTHER STATES I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN PUBLIC
SAFETY WOULD BE. YOU KNOW WOULD
REALLY HANG IN THE BALANCE ON
THE OTHER HAND IT' REALLY A
SHAME THAT THERE ARE STATES OUT
THERE THAT ARE PUTTING BOUNTIES
OUT ON WOMEN WHO ARE JUST
SEEKING TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL
THE TIMING OF WHEN THEY ARE TO
HAVE OR NOT HAVE A CHILD OR OR
CARRY A CHILD THAT THERE ARE
STATES THAT ARE- CRIMINALIZING
OF PARENTS AND DOCTORS WHO WANT
TO HELP THEIR CHILDREN WITH
GENDER AFFIRMING SURGERY IT'S
ACTUALLY THIS BILL SHOWS THAT
THOSE VERY ACTIONS ON ONLY DO
THEY ENDANGER THE SAFETY AND
HEALTH AND THE WELL BEING OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. BUT THEY PUT
ALL OF OUR SAFETY AT RISK
BECAUSE OF EXACTLY THIS KIND OF
TREPIDATION TO SHARE INFORMATION
WITH STATES WHO ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY- THREATENING AND-
CURTAILING THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THEIR CITIZENS AND CRIMINALIZING
PEOPLE ACTING WITHIN THEIR OWN
CIVIL RIGHTS SO- THAT'S WHY THIS
IS DIFFICULT AND I THINK UP
SETTING FOR A LOT OF US- AND- I
DO A REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING THOSE CONCERNS AS
SERIOUSLY AS YOU HAVE AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT. I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THE
BILL TODAY BECAUSE IT IS GOING
TO THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE WHERE
I'M HOPING THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
REFINE THIS BILL SO THAT THOSE
STATES DON'T USE THIS AS A WAY
OF HUNTING DOWN- YOU KNOW
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AS THEY
SEEM INTENT ON DOING A BUT AT
THE SAME TIME ALLOWING US TO
SHARE INFORMATION TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC SAFE. SO WITH THAT CAN WE
HAVE A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MELCHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE OVER THOSE COMMENTS
WE CONTINUE TO- KEEP AN OPEN
DOOR POLICY HE- ADDRESS THESE-
THAT MEMBERS HAVE BROUGHT
FORWARD- CERTAINLY TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE A BALANCE
WITHIN PUBLIC SAFETY- WE SEE
RETAIL THEFT ON THE ON THE RISE.
WE SEE CERTAIN TYPES OF-
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. ARE MOVING
FORWARD- AND- PACKED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT I
THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO COME TOGETHER TO STRIKE A
BALANCE ON ON WHAT IT IS THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO. MAKE A BUILT
STRONGER IN THE PROTECT PROTECT
WOMEN'S RIGHTS PROTECT OUR-
IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN A MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT. VIOLATE
ANYTHING THAT CALIFORNIA'S VALID
VALUES ACT HAS MOVED FORWARD ON
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO START THE
DISCUSSION OF HOW DO WE BUILD
THAT BALANCE TO ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND THAT THOSE ARE THAT
WE CAN- HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
THROUGH A PROCESS LIKE THIS
WITHOUT VIOLATING OTHERS OTHERS
OUT THERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THOSE IN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE- CONTINUE
TO HAVE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE COULD GET TO
THAT POINT. WHERE THAT BALANCE
IS STRUCK. THANK YOU I'M WITH
THAT CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE. DO PASS TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NOT VOTING
BERMAN BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY I DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA NOT VOTING
LEE. LEAN NOT VOTING MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN NOT
VOTING O'DONNELL. WARD WARD I
WICKES WICKES HI. EIGHT ZERO
IT'S TERRIBLE HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GOING TO
PRESENT MY TWO BILLS AND
MINISTER FONG CHAIR THE MEETING. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
CHAIR YOU CAN PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
AND I WILL BE BRIEF ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT IS A
SEPARATE TO SET UP A TASK FORCE
TO HELP OR UNDERSTAND WHY ARE
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE MOST ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW POST CODE
AND HOW THEY CAN MOVE INTO THE
NEXT GENERATION AND- TO HELP US
KNOW HOW TO BEST SUPPORT THEIR
EFFORTS WITH THAT I WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL AS- WE START I
BELIEVE WITH. BRIAN TAYLOR IN
PERSON AND THEY WILL GO TO IAN
GRIFFITHS OF THE SEAMLESS BAY OF
SEAMLESS BAY AREA ON THE PHONE.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THIS IS A
SUPPORT SUPPORT. BOTH SIDES. TWO
MINUTES IS ON YES NOT A MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND BRIAN
TAYLOR PROFESSOR OF URBAN
PLANNING AND PUBLIC POLICY AND
DIRECTOR OF THE INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AT UCLA.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A
BROADLY REPRESENTATIVE PUBLIC
TRANSIT AND INTERCITY RAIL
RECOVERY TASK FORCE. A
CONFINEMENT REMARKS TODAY ON HOW
PUBLIC TRANSIT CALIFORNIA WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROPOSED TASK
FORCE. FIRST BY PUBLIC TRANSIT
REFERRING TO THE BUSES VANS IN
VANS AND TRAINS THAT SERVE THE
DAILY TRAVEL NEEDS OF RIDERS IN
NOT TO LONG DISTANCE INTERCITY
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES. I AND
OTHER RESEARCHERS AT THE
INSTITUTE OF TRANSPORTATION
STUDIES OF THE UC SYSTEM HAVE
BEEN EXAMINING PUBLIC TRANSIT.
AND WAYS TO IMPROVE THE MODE FOR
MANY YEARS AND WE INTEND TO DO
SO AND IT CAN SUPPORT THIS
COMMITTEE IN THAT. REGARD
LEADING UP TO THE PANDEMIC OUR
RESEARCH FOUND THAT PUBLIC
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP WAS REPAIR
ROADING IN A LARGE PART DUE TO
INCREASED AUTO ACCESS IN TERMS
OF BOTH HIGHER CAR OWNERSHIP.
AND RISING RIGHT HE'LL USE
PARTICULARLY AMONG LESS
ADVANTAGE TRAVELERS. THE
COMPRISE A LARGE SHARE OF
TRANSIT USERS. IN THE PANDEMIC
THIS SCRIPT SWITCHED IS MORE
ADVANTAGE TRAVELERS HAVE
ABANDONED TRANSIT IN PARTICULAR
FORMER DOWNTOWN AND OTHER OFFICE
CENTER COMMUTERS SHIFTED TO
WORKING FROM HOME. OR DRIVING
WHILE MANY LOWER INCOME
ESSENTIAL WORKERS HAVE CONTINUED
TO RIDE. SO WELL MOST TRAVEL BY
OTHER MEANS HAS RECOVERED SINCE
THE START OF THE PANDEMIC PUBLIC
TRANSIT USE IS STUCK AT ROUGHLY
ONE THIRD TO TWO THIRDS PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS. AND MOST CREDIT
AT CURRENT TRANSIT USERS A
DISADVANTAGE TRAVELERS.
PERSISTENT DEPRESSED RIDERSHIP
IS DEPRESSED FARE REVENUES WELL
THE THREE PANDEMIC RESCUE BILLS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL OF HELP
TRANSIT SYSTEMS WHETHER THE
POOREST OF THE PANDEMIC.
FINANCIAL SHORTFALLS ARE LOOMING
FOR MANY PUBLIC TRANSIT SYSTEMS
IS A FEDERAL FUNDING RUNS OUT.
AGAINST THIS TROUBLING BACKDROP
CALIFORNIA'S ASKING A LOT OF ITS
TRANSIT SYSTEMS TO REDUCE CAR
DEPENDENCE IN TRAFFIC CONGESTION
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND SLOW
CLIMATE CHANGE. PROMOTE
CONTACTED ELEMENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDE ACCESS FOR ALL.
BUT SHE EVEN THESE GOALS DEPENDS
ON PEOPLE RIDING TRANSIT. ANY
USE OF TRANSIT NEAR HEAD IS
GOING TO BE AFFECTED BY MYRIAD
FACTORS INCLUDING THE
ORGANIZATION FUNDING AND
OPERATION OF TRANSIT SYSTEMS. AS
WELL AS PUBLIC POLICIES GUIDING
LAND DEVELOPMENT IN MANAGING
DRIVING THAT ARE BEYOND THE
PURVIEW OF TRANSIT MANAGERS.
FENCES RECOVERY MUST BE
ADDRESSED HOLISTICALLY WHICH IS
WHY THE PROPOSED TASK FORCE IS
NEEDED TO HELP CHART A NEW
STRATEGIC DIRECTION MISTER
TAYLOR YOU TWO MINUTES ARE UP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR GRIFFITHS IN A PROCEED AGAIN
THIS BILL HAS. A SUPPORT SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS IAN GRIFFITHS AND ON THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR HUMAN BAY
AREA A NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES
FOR A INTEGRATED. EQUITABLE
WORLD CLASS TRYING TO CONTENT
ACROSS. THE KOBE AREA AND BEYOND
. ON THE IN THE COURT OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT. FINALISTS
SICKLY STUDYING GOVERNANCE AND
FUNDING REFORMS THE TASK FORCE
CREATED BY THE BILL CAN LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE OF
LEGISLATION AND FUNDING REFORMS
THEY CAN MAKE TRANSIT FAR MORE
EFFICIENT RELIABLE OPINION AND-
AND HIGHER RIDERSHIP. ALL THE
TIME AND- HAS BEEN IN DECLINE-
IN RECENT YEARS INCLUDING THE
FOR THE PANDEMIC AS A WRITER
IT'S NOT HARD TO SEE WHY. OFTEN
DON'T COME FREQUENTLY ENOUGH TO
BE USEFUL SERVICES ARE RUN IN
ISOLATION AT THE COURT TO
ATHLETES GREAT NETWORK THEY
DON'T LOGICALLY CONNECT TO EACH
OTHER IN MANY CASES PROVIDERS.
AND PAY SEPARATE FARES FOR EACH
LEG OF THEIR JOURNEY WHICH CAN
MAKE TRYING TO MARKET AND HAVE
BEEN DRIVING ME BURDEN FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON LOW INCOME
IN TRANSIT AND IN CALIFORNIA. A
RECENT MINETA TRANSPORTATION
INSTITUTE STUDY FOUND THAT
REGION HI TRANSIT USE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD HAVE COMMON
CHARACTERISTICS THAT ARE
REPLICABLE IN CALIFORNIA.
INTEGRATED FARES COORDINATED
CASUALTY REGIONAL COORDINATION
AUTHORITIES CONSOLIDATED RAIL
AGENCIES AND INCREASED LEVEL OF
SERVICE FUNDED BY RELIABLE EIGHT
FUNDING SOURCES. THE PROPOSED
TRANSIT INTERCITY RAIL RECOVERY
TASK FORCE IN EIGHTY NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THEREFORE CRITICAL
TO THE SURVIVAL AND GROWTH A
TREND IN CALIFORNIA I DID.
INVESTIGATE ALL OF THESE CORE
ISSUES. OTHER REGIONS HAVE YOU
SIMILAR STATE PROCESS EACH BRING
ABOUT THAT RENTAL FUNDING FOR.
THAT ELECTED IN. TRANSIT YOU.
THAT THE AUTHOR REPORTED AT THAT
EFFORTS WITHIN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA THAT WE HAVE BEEN PART
OF TO BRING ABOUT A MORE
COORDINATED EFFECTIVE TRANSIT
SYSTEM TO OUR REGION. WE WELCOME
THAT THE BILL WILL BRING
STATEWIDE FOCUS ON GOVERNMENT
FUNDING THAT CAN COMPLEMENT EACH
REGIONAL EFFORTS BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY ARE LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE TRANSIT
SYSTEM. SHOULD ALL WORK AS ONE
TEAM WITH THE TIME TO THE RIDER
TO BE ABLE TO ATTRACT MORE
PEOPLE TO SUSTAINABLE BONTA
TRANSIT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
SO WE'LL GO TO THE- THE ROOM
HERE IS ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD. THE
NONE. WHEN I GO TO THE PHONES IF
YOU ARE. GOING TO SIT SPEAK AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO IT AB
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PROCEED MR OPERATOR. THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL AB
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT. WE GO TO
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARK BROOKS A
BATCH INSERT FROM STREETS FOR
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A BLUE
RIBBON TASK FORCE ON THE TOPIC
THANK YOU. AND NO OTHER LINES IN
Q. YOU MAY PROCEED MISTER CHAIR.
OF THE OPERATOR BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. TINO QUESTIONS
MANAGERS AT CLOSE JUST WHAT WE
NEED TO HELP OUR TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN THIS WILL HELP GIVE
US THAT ROAD MAP I WOULD REQUEST
AN IPHONE WITH THE MOTION SECOND
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FONG.
FONG AYE BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM DALY
HI DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON GIPSON AYE KALRA KALRA I
LI LI I'M MEDINA. THE MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN I O'DONNELL. WARD
WARD I WICKS. TEN ZERO TEN ZERO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL NOW GO TO FILE I'M
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
MENTOR YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WANT TO THANK MY COMMITTEE
ESPECIALLY FOR THEIR HARD WORK
OVER THE PAST MONTH THIS BILL
WILL REDUCE RACIAL AND WEALTH
WEALTH BASED DISPARITIES IN
ENFORCEMENT OF MINOR TRAFFIC
LAWS WHILE MAINTAINING ROAD
SAFETY BY MAKING THE FOLLOWING
POLICY CHANGES ELIMINATING
LICENSES AND SUSPENSIONS BASED
ON FAILURE TO APPEAR IN COURT.
AND MAKING THE FIRST TWO
OFFENSES AN INFRACTION FOR
DRIVING WITHOUT A LICENSE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS CAME FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE AND REMEMBER THESE
OFFENSES ARE ARE FINANCIAL IN
NATURE THIS DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING ABOUT TAKING AWAY
PEOPLE'S LICENSES FOR DO YOU
WISE- THOSE TYPES OF TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON AS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY DIANA BECTON
OF CONTRA COSTA AND TYLER NICHOL
SMITH WITH THE LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES. THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH WE'LL
START WITH CONTRA COSTA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BACK THEN AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO- TYLER SMITH SO- A
DISTRICT THIRTY BACK IN PLEASE
PARTY WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ON THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AT THE HERBS ARE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND PRIOR TO THAT I
ALSO SERVED AS JUDGE AND
PRESIDING JUDGE OF THE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX- AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX WILL
REQUIRE DRIVING WITHOUT
POSSESSION OF A LICENSE TO BE
CHARGED AS AN INFRACTION FOR THE
FIRST TWO VIOLATIONS. AND IN
LICENSE SUSPENSIONS FOR FAILURE
TO APPEAR IN COURT. AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF COURSE I AM
COMMITTED TO KEEPING OUR STREETS
SAFE FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
DANGEROUS ANIMALS ARE COMMITTED
TO SAFEGUARDING OUR COMMUNITY.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW A PERSON'S
LICENSE TO DRIVE CAN BE
SUSPENDED SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
FAILED TO APPEAR IN COURT. THIS
IS REALLY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND
INEFFECTIVE WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
SHOW UP FOR COURT. WHEN WE TAKE
AWAY THEIR ABILITY TO LEGALLY
DRIVE WE MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO COME TO COURT AND
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY NO EVIDENCE
THAT THE THREAT TO LICENSE
SUSPENSION. WORKS TO GET PEOPLE
TO COURT NO ONE EVEN KNOWS IF IT
IS HOT AND COMFORTABLE FUNCTION
FOR DEALING TO APPEAR. THE
PRACTICE IS JUST NOT AFFECT IT
JUST INEFFECTIVE. IT IS IN THE
INTERESTS OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE COMMUNITY THAT EVERYONE
WHO PROVIDES BE LICENSED AND IN
SHORT. THE REASON MANY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS LIKE MYSELF NOW CHARGE
DRIVING WITHOUT POSSESSION OF A
LICENSE AT THE FRACTION. THAT
THIS BEHAVIOR IS NOT ASSOCIATED
WITH DANGEROUS DRIVING OR EVEN
PUBLIC SAFETY MORE POLITELY IT
IS ASSOCIATED WITH POVERTY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT BLACK
AND LATINO PEOPLE. IT MAKES NO
SENSE TO CHARGE TECHNICAL
VIOLATION- OF THE CODE THAT
ACTUALLY CAN CARRY A RISK OF
SERIOUS HARM TO PEOPLE LIKE
SPEEDING. LIKE OTHER- AND OTHER
CHARGES LIKE SPEEDING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON. I
THANK VERY MUCH S. A TYLER SMITH
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TERRY NICHOLS SMITH AM
CURRENTLY THE MANAGING ATTORNEY
FOR THE VETERAN CHEF WITH CENTER
AT THE LEGALLY FOUNDATION OF LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX. I'VE BEEN TRAINING HAVE
THIRD HUNDREDS OF LOW INCOME
CLIENTS MANY OF WHOM ARE BLACK
AND BROWN HAVE STRUGGLED TO
OVERCOME THE COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES ANDROMEDA
FACILITATED WITH THE CURRENT
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS AND LYFT
INSPECTION CONVENTION ACTIONS
LIKE A NEW CONNECTION IN YOUR
LIFE BENCHING CAN KNOCK AN
ALREADY UNSTABLE INDIVIDUAL OR
FAMILY FRTHER OUT OFWHACK AND
PUSH THEM FURTHER AWAY FROM THE
BILITY. ASCENSION AWAKENING OF
THE LIFE EXPECTANCY TO APPEAR
FOR EXAMPLE PLACES EVEN MORE
CONSTRAINT ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE OFTEN THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
TRANSPORTATION FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO SELL
THEIR OBLIGATIONS AND IT'S OFTEN
THAT THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE THE LICENSE SUSPENSION
UNTIL THEY'RE STOPPED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DUE TO THE DMV
RECORD NOTICES. NEVER EVEN
REACHING THEM. WE BE LIKE TO
THANK THERE. TO THE AND- TO I
MEDICAL DUE TO THEIR LACK OF
TRANSFER. OR RISK IT ALL JUSTICE
. NOT ANOTHER TO BUT BE ABOUT
THE CONVO FOR ALREADY DOING.
WHAT THEY CAN'T SURVIVE. BECAUSE
THEY WERE UNABLE TO MAKE IT TO
COURT. FURTHERMORE THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES THAT
COME WITH THOSE IN THE COMMUTER
CONNECTION AND ELECTED
SUSPENSION. IN FAN EVEN YEARS
AFTER THE INITIAL INCIDENT WHILE
MISDEMEANORS ARE CONSIDERED TO
BE LESS. THAN A FELONY OR
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION IS IN NO
WAY HARM TO THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
RECEIVED THEM. THE CONNECTION IS
A PERMANENT MARK ON THEIR RECORD
EVEN ONCE IT'S EXPANSION. THIS
MEANS THAT EVERY PUBLIC
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT OUR LIFE INSURANCE
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL GO THROUGH-
WILL BRING INTO QUESTION THEIR
JUDGMENT AND THEIR APPEAL
ABILITY. AND MAKE THEM LESS
VALUABLE THAN AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
NO RECORD. AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX- WILL BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY REDUCING THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES. AND
LONG LASTING HARM ON THAT ARE
CAUSED BY BOTH THE NEXT MERE
CONVICTION- AND BE. A LICENSE
SUSPENSION THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU TYLER. AND THERE'S NO A- ON
FIVE SO. WHO WHICH TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYWAY WOULD TO
COME FOR ANY WHO LIKE FORWARD
AND SPEAK AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
TO. AB TWENTY SIMPLY SIX PLEASE
COME FORWARD. CENA WILL GO TO
THE OPERATOR. PLEASE PROCEED
OPERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD FIRST WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ATTACHMENTS-
EXPRESSING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA THE
WESTERN CENTER FOR LONG POVERTY.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION A FAIR CHANCE
PROJECT INITIATED JUSTICE YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND
SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO OTHER LINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
. A MISTER KALRA IS OF LOVE THE
BILL THE ADD ON HAS CAUGHT THE
MANAGER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THE MANAGER WAS THAT
CLOSE HAPPY TO ADD YOU MISTER
KALRA AND I WOULD. REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE MOTION SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO PASSED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG NO BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES NO GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA
KALRA I LEE. LEE I MEDINA INA I
NAZARIAN. OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX. FILE ITEM YEAH FILE
ITEM ELEVEN. THE SYRIAN I WENT.
WHEN NO O'DONNELL. DONALD I WARD
. WARD I WICKS WICKS I. ELEVEN
TO ELEVEN VOTE ELEVEN TO THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU NOW WE'LL GO BACK AND
TO- TAKE ROLL CALL ON ALL OF THE
ITEMS. I DID WAS ON CONSENT
BERMAN HI. AND I DAVIS. DAVIES I
GIPSON GIPSON AYE WHEN I
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I'D WARD
WARD I WICKS WIXII RIGHT THAT'S
EVERYBODY FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM ONE AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES. FILE ITEM
ONE. DAVIES I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
I WENT WHEN I DONALD DONNELL AYE
WICKES WICKES I. FOR ROOF
CURRENT VOTE FOR FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT
FOURTEEN. FILE ITEM TWO AB TWO
ZERO FIVE SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ONE. FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES DAVIES NOW
LEE LEAVE I NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
WENT. WHEN NO. WELL DONALD
O'DONNELL I WARD. WARD I LICKS
WICKS I. ELEVEN THREE FIVE OF
ELEVEN OR THREE THAT BILL IS OUT
. FILE ITEM FOR AB TWO THOUSAND
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO DALY.
DALY NO DAVIES DAVIES I KALRA.
KALRA NOT VOTING. HEY LEE LEAD
NOT VOTING. NAZARIAN THE SYRIAN
I'VE WENT. WHEN I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I WORK LORD I MOVE.
FULL ZERO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
. FILE ITEM FIVE AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO
CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES DAVIES I
KALRA KALRA I LEE ME I IS ERIN
NAZARIAN I WENT WHEN I O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I WICKS. WICKS I.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN THAT BILL
IS OUT. FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE
CUNNINGHAM. LEE LEAD NOT VOTING
. THIS AARON. THE SYRIAN NOT
VOTING WHEN. UPPALA IN SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE. WHEN
NOT VOTING O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I
WARD WARD NO. NINE ZERO NINE ONE
NINE ONE THAT BILL IS OUT. RIGHT
FILE ITEM EIGHT TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES
CHANGE THE NOT VOTING. OKAY.
THIS IS DONE IS AARON. TWENTY
ONE NINETY TWO. I NAZARIAN I.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I. TEN ONE
AND ONE THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM TEN NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO BERMAN.
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. NAZARIAN.
ABSTAINING OKAY NAZARIAN
ABSTAINED OF DONALD O'DONNELL I
WICKS WIXII. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TO
CUNNINGHAM. NOT HERE. FINAL
FINAL. ELEVEN TO. AS THAT BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
ARE ADJOURNED.